ich auch zu solchen querfrontendenzen
kommen wir haben es ja gerade am
Wochenende in Tschechien gesehen wo
70.000 Menschen
Kommunisten rechtsextreme marschiert
sind gegen hohe Energiepreise alle waren
vielen Dank für dieses Phönix
nachgefragt am Dienstagmorgen tschüss
ja und die Achse Bonn Berlin steht heute
quasi in einer Standleitung Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer denn sie
sehen es mein Kollege Erhard schärfer
steht bereits bereit vor der
Haushaltsdebatte im Deutschen Bundestag
Beginn der haushaltswoche hat er Gäste
da und deswegen gebe ich jetzt direkt ab
nach Berlin zu Erhard schärfer
danke Claudia Davis und was vorhin ja
schon mal von Zauberei die Rede war im
Gespräch mit Rainer Holznagel hier ist
hat ein bisschen was von einem
Zauberkasten hat auch der Haushalt 23
finde ich jedenfalls um fast 445
Milliarden Euro also rund 50 Milliarden
weniger als der aktuelle und trotzdem
will die Koalition mehr Fortschritt
Wagen also möglichst viel von ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen wie durch
Zauberei sollen Bürgerinnen entlastet
werden Investitionen zudem steigen und
bei all dem soll auch noch die
Schuldenbremse eingehalten werden was
unter anderem durch einen schon
bekannten Trick passiert in dem man
nämlich eine sonderschuld in ein
Sondervermögen deklariert und sie ein
bisschen außerhalb des eigentlichen
Haushalt des platziert hat und wir
fragen uns aber trotzdem was passiert
eigentlich wenn das weiße Kaninchen
namens Wirtschaftswachstum nicht so aus
dem zylinderhopf hüpft wie erwartet und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger
hoch ob das ganze dann insgesamt noch
aufgehen wird fragen wir mal nach bei
Dennis Rohde dem haushaltspolitischen
Sprecher der spd-f Telefon guten Morgen
ihnen und Helge braun ist bei uns der
Vorsitzende des Haushaltsausschusses und
Mitglied der cdu/csu-fraktion auch ihnen
schönen guten Morgen Herr Rohde bevor
wir uns der Frage Magie oder solides
Handwerk widmen werfen wir noch mal
einen Blick auf das entlassungspaket das
am Wochenende beschlossen worden ist wie
und wo finden sich eigentlich diese 65
Milliarden die viel zitierten die die
BürgerInnen entlasten sollen wieder in
diesem Haushalt im neuen die finden sich
ja in verschiedenen Haushalten wieder
die finden sich im Bundeshaushalt wieder
der hat allein im Jahr 2022 deutlich
Umsatzsteuer Mehreinnahmen der findet
sich in den landeshaushalten wieder wir
sind ja zum Beispiel bereit das neun
euro-ticket mit 1,5 Milliarden Euro Code
zu finanzieren das eigentlich nur
eigentliche Aufgabe der Länder auch die
haben Mehrwertsteuer Mehreinnahmen
allein in den ersten sechs Monaten
generiert die finden sich zum Teil im
Sondervermögen Energie und klimaform
wieder wenn wir die Aussetzung der CO2
mit der co2-preises besprechen und die
werden in einem System des Strompreises
selbst generiert wir wollen ja eine
umgekehrte EEG-Umlage schaffen um diesen
Effekt den wir gerade beim Strompreis
haben das eigentlich erneuerbarer
günstiger sind aber teurer verkauft
werden umzudrehen also an ganz vielen
verschiedenen Positionen das Phänomen
was ich meine und wie kommen auch gleich
sofort zu ihnen das Phänomen dass ich
meine dieser Entwurf der heute
eingebracht wird ist ja besteht ja schon
ein paar Wochen irgendwie also ist auch
älter als der Beschluss vom Wochenende
und trotzdem verändert sich nichts im
Haushalt also da hat sich ja ist ja
nichts dazu gekommen
natürlich wird sich was im Haushalt
verändern wir starten ja jetzt mit dem
parlamentarischen Verfahren und wir
wissen dass wir im Herbst ja noch mal
auch eine neue steuerprognose bekommen
und auf die werden wir dann natürlich
auch noch mal reagieren und Sie haben
gerade gesagt was passiert jetzt
eigentlich wenn das Wirtschaftswachstum
untergeht wenn das Wirtschaftswachstum
runtergeht darf der Staat mehr Schulden
machen weil dann die
konjunkturkomponente der Schuldenbremse
schwächer ist also wird es an anderer
Stelle wieder ausgeglichen ich glaube
dass du schon solides Handwerk mit dem
man die 65 Milliarden finanzieren kann
damit sie bei einer Koalition
wahrscheinlich noch mal spannend Herr
Braun ist das Paket zumindest in einigen
Punkten auf dem richtigen Weg oder ist
die Koalition da offen völlig falschen
Pfad ihrer Meinung nach also
grundsätzlich ist es in dieser Phase
unerlässlich das entlastungspakete gibt
aber wir haben ja jetzt auch schon
einige Beispiele gesehen mit dem
Tankrabatt zum Beispiel oder dem neuen
euro-ticket sind Dinge die haben
sozusagen die Haushalte stark belastet
sind aber schon rum also jetzt wenn die
eigentlichen Probleme auftreten wirken
die gar nicht mehr man muss einfach
sagen wenn wir die Ursachen von
Inflation und energiepreisschock nicht
schnell bekämpfen sondern versuchen mit
einen neuen entlastungspaketen zu
finanzieren dann dreht sich die
Preisspirale weiter und dann haben
Bürger und der Staat relativ schnell
ihre Taschen das fehlt ihrer Meinung
nach ich glaube die Angebotsseite also
Energie einkaufen und Energie
produzieren das ist ganz entscheidend
Inflation ist eine zutiefst unsoziales
Ereignis weil sie alle stärker belastet
und diejenigen die am wenigsten Geld in
der Tasche haben können sich am
wenigsten wehren und eins muss man sagen
die Dimension ist so groß dass wir mit
allen Anstrengungen in
entlastungspaketen ob sie wuchtig sind
oder nicht und das spüren die Bürger
auch immer nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
bekämpfen können viel trifft die Bürger
eben doch und deshalb ist das Thema des
Tages aus meiner Sicht diese Frage
produzieren wir mehr Energie Stichwort
neue Brennstäbe zum Beispiel auch für
Kernkraftwerke das löst das Problem an
der Ursache wenn wir in das Jahr 2023
mit einem ungelösten Energieproblem bei
weiter hoher Inflation gehen glaube ich
auch sind die Eckwerte dieses Haushalts
in Gefahr Helge Braun hat unter anderem
den Inflationsausgleich angesprochen da
wollen sie ja unter anderem jetzt die
sogenannten zufallsgewinne abschöpfen
und damit auch den BürgerInnen helfen
und den Bürgern haben Sie irgendeine
konkrete Idee schon von der Umsetzung
wie das gelingen kann und was da
überhaupt zusammenkommt an Geld was dann
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann das
Besondere ist ja dass das nicht über den
Bundeshaushalt geschieht sondern ist
geschieht ja im System der
strommarkterzeugung an sich werden wir
momentan ein Effekt dass der Strompreis
festgelegt wird nach dem teuersten
Einkaufspreis das ist Gas das heißt
Unternehmen die im großen zum Beispiel
erneuerbare Einkaufen machen gerade
milliardengewinde und wir wollen jetzt
die EEG-Umlage die ja so ausgestaltet
war dass man damals gesagt hat was
kosten erneuerbare mehr und das geht in
der Rückvergütung quasi umdrehen und
sagen was sind erneuerbare günstige und
das geht in der Rückvergütung im System
selbst das wird nicht über den
Bundeshaushalt fließen deshalb ist es
auch nicht für den Bundeshaushalt zu
beziehen und sonst ein System in sich
ich gehe aber davon aus dass da
zweistellige Milliarden Summen zu
zustande kommen werden das sind
zumindest die Berechnung die ich kenne
also ähnlich optimistisch also das muss
vor allen Dingen diese Korrekturen am
strommarktdesign müssen schnell erfolgen
weil wir ja die Preisspitzen aktuell
schon sehen und das eine sehr
komplizierte Operation deshalb ist mir
auch wichtig dass wir gerade bei den
Entlastungsmaßnahmen und so jetzt auch
transparent im Haushalt abbilden was
bedeutet das eigentlich also so als
Vorsitzender des Haushaltsausschusses
dieses sozusagen diese Aussage Zauberer
Finanzminister irgendwo finden wir immer
noch Geld das macht mir große Sorgen
weil am Ende auch versteckte Schulden
müssen von irgendwem am Ende
zurückbezahlt werden der fdp-haushälter
Fricke rechnet mit habe ich gelesenem
härtesten und umfangreichsten
Haushaltsberatungen seit 2002 musste ich
erstmal nachgucken das war der erste
Haushalt in Euro 2002 womit rechnen sie
als Vorsitzender des
Haushaltsausschusses also ich glaube
auch dass wir wollen ja den Haushalt im
November abschließen dann sind wir
mutmaßlich Mitten sozusagen im Zentrum
der aktuellen und deshalb glaube ich
auch dass gerade in den letzten Tagen
dann noch sehr viel Verantwortung auf
dem Haushaltsausschuss landet aber dafür
sind wir auch da die Regierung machten
Entwurf schlägt was vor und wir haben
die Verantwortung zu beschließen was
dann wirklich gemacht wird im Vorfeld
gab es Kritik an dem
Haushaltsplan für das nächste Jahr unter
anderem vom Bundesrechnungshof aus dem
Entwurf werde die wahre Lage der
Bundesfinanzen nicht deutlich hieß es da
der Haushaltsausschuss kennt den Bericht
natürlich wie ehrlich ist dieser Entwurf
den sie da heute oder der heute ins
Parlament geht ich glaube dass jedem
Haushälter jeder Haushälterin die Ware
Lage des Bundeshaus bekannt ist und auch
das was der Bundesrechnungshof
kritisiert dass er sagt da gibt es ein
Sondervermögen was bedient wird da gibt
es den Kernhaushalt das ist ja alles
überschaust ist alles transparent das
kann man nachlesen natürlich ist es so
dass Aufgaben aus dem Kernhaushalt zum
Beispiel in Energie und klimafor
ausgelagert wurden aber das machen wir
seit vielen Jahren so ich finde nicht
dass das getrickse ist aber eigentlich
ist es ja trotzdem beschummelt weil die
die zusätzlichen Schulden sind ja da
auch wenn sie jetzt nicht in dem
eigentlichen Haushaltsplan stehen die
Schulden des
energie-vermögensbundeswehr sind ja
verfassungsrechtlich von der
Schuldenbremse ausgenommen worden sie
bekommen irgendwann einen eigenen
Tilgungsplan das hat das Parlament auch
mit den Stimmen der Union so beschlossen
ich weiß nicht was daran intransparent
sein soll es ist ein gesetzesbeschuss
eine Grundgesetzänderung gewesen das
kann man im Grundgesetz nachlesen also
ich finde die Kritik des
Bundesrechnungshofes an dieser Stelle
etwas überzogen Herr Braun ich finde die
Kritik sehr gerechtfertigt weil man ja
sagen muss es ist nicht nur das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr was wir mit
einer Grundgesetzänderung sehr klar
aufgestellt haben sondern ein
Nachtragshaushalt ein ergänzungshaushalt
und weitere Sondervermögen das ist in
der Summe so intransparent ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir das was wirklich die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zurückzahlen
müssen auch wieder stärker einfach im
Bundeshaushalt abbilden dass man
darunter die Zahl sieht was sind unsere
neuen Schulden das wäre glaube ich sehr
sehr sinnvoll können Sie sofort sagen
auch direkt drauf reagieren was ich noch
hinzufügen wollte ist es wird ja
eigentlich die Schuldenbremse wenn man
es mal richtig zusammenrechnet wird ja
eigentlich nicht wirklich eingehalten
bei allem Argumenten die sie eben
angeführt haben
erstmal suggeriert Helge braun ja gerade
es gäbe mehrere Haushalte das stimmt
natürlich nicht das weiß auch der
Nachtragshaushalt verändert den Haushalt
der ergänzungshaushalt verändert den
Haushaltsentwurf am Ende gibt es ein
Haushalt es gibt nicht eine
ergänzungshaushalt ein Nachtragshaushalt
ein Haushalt sondern ein transparenten
Haushalt in dem man alles das nachlesen
kann in dem das zusammengefasst ist und
das ist transparent aber eigentlich ist
die Nettokreditaufnahme nicht 17
Milliarden sondern 78 Milliarden habe
ich gelesen die Nettokreditaufnahme die
in die Schuldenbremse reingerechnet wird
sind 17,2 Milliarden da gibt es
Rechnungen wie mit Sondervermögen
Transferleistungen wie zum Beispiel
Zuschüsse an die Bahn zu berechnen sind
aber das war auch zur Zeit wo die Union
regiert hat so da hat sich nichts dran
geändert
aber getrickst es ein bisschen Trick ist
doch dabei wenn man viermal so viele
Schulden letzten Endes als Bürger
zurückzahlen muss gegenüber dem was man
offiziell in die Schuldenbremse
reinrechnet muss natürlich sich fragen
was ist dann die Schuldenbremse noch
wert und deshalb müssen wir glaube ich
dazu zurückkommen zu dem Grundgedanke
Grundgedanke ist wir wollen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Zukunft die
junge Generation die auch Krisen
durchstehen werden muss nicht zusätzlich
belasten und deshalb glaube ich ist die
Grundfrage nicht was rechnen wir rein
und raus sondern wie hoch ist die
Belastung der Bevölkerung der Zukunft
tut mir leid aber auch das ist fachlich
nicht richtig weil getilgt werden muss
nur das was über die Schuldenbremse
hinausgeht das wird jedes Jahr
ausgewiesen die normale
Nettokreditaufnahme ist nicht unter der
tilgungsverpflichtung des Bundes der
Bund hat historisch sowieso nur zweimal
Schulden getilgt während der großen
Koalition ansonsten hat der prolongiert
also wenn man jetzt sagt die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger müssen wissen was alles in
nächster Zeit getickt werden muss dann
geht das nur über das was über die
Schulen Bremse hinausgeht und das weisen
wir in einen eigenen Beschluss mit Kanz
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag aus also
transparenter geht es auch an der Stelle
nicht
also ich glaube die Zahl die der
Rechnungshof hier erarbeitet hat war ja
insofern neu die konnte man im Haushalt
nicht nachlesen sondern dazu muss man
sozusagen aufblättern was wir an
verschiedenen Beschlüssen der Ampel in
alleine in dieser kurzen Regierungszeit
hatten und deshalb glaube ich
haushaltstransparenz eine Rückbesinnung
auf den Kernhaushalt als das zentrale
Instrument würde ich mir sehr wünschen
es gibt eine Menge Unwegbarkeiten in
diesen Zeiten die Frage ist sind die
Zinsausgaben hinreichend kalkuliert wir
wissen nicht wie es mir dem ukrainekrieg
weitergeht wir wissen es nicht wie es
mit den Energiekosten weitergeht mit der
und allem was dazugehört welcher welcher
Bereich macht ihnen als Haushälter im
Moment die meisten Sorgen
sicherlich die implerbezogen auf den
Haushalt sicherlich zum einen die
Inflation was die Ausgabenseite des
Bundes angeht aber natürlich macht mir
am meisten Sorgen die Energiekosten die
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu stemmen
haben und die sind natürlich auch sehr
haushaltsrelevant weil wenn wir an eine
Situation kommen dass die weiter davon
laufen dann werden wir auch über weitere
Entlastungen diskutieren müssen am Ende
muss ja zählen dass wir die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger nicht alleine lassen und das
wird auch diese Haushaltsverhandlungen
bringen was wären ihre Mittel auch aus
Unionsfraktion Sicht ja also ich glaube
das Wichtigste das habe ich vorhin
angedeutet ist dass wir diese
Energiekrise beseitigen dass die
Inflation aufhört Inflation ist so etwas
unsoziales und die Dimension dieses
Problems so groß dass wir mit
entlastungspaketen dagegen nicht
ankommen und im Bundeshaushalt müssen
wir natürlich auch auf diejenigen achten
die sich gegen diese Preisspirale gar
nicht wehren können das sind zum
Beispiel unsere Krankenhäuser die an
einer öffentlichen Finanzierung über die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung hängen
das ist zum Beispiel die deutsche
Wissenschaft unsere Hochschulen die auch
alle die Steigerungen haben die aber
nicht von sich aus irgendwie die Preise
erhöhen können sondern die einer
staatlichen Finanzierung unterliegen und
die natürlich jetzt auch alle Fragen
kriegen wir diese Mehrkosten erstattet
bei einem Bundeshaushalt der so auf
Kante genäht ist
Dennis Rohde vielen Dank dass ihr heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind Herr gebraut
vielen Dank auch Ihnen in ein zwei
Minuten fängt die haushaltswoche dann
auch richtig an den Plenum heute etwas
verspätet wegen der Sonderveranstaltung
wegen des Staatsbesuchs des israelischen
Staatspräsidenten vielen Dank dass Sie
hier gewesen sind wir freuen uns auf
spannende Button wir werden sie auch
überwiegend live übertragen und dann den
einen oder anderen von Ihnen hier
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal sehen live
im Programm danke ihnen sie dürfen jetzt
reingehen ich wende mich unseren
Publikum noch ein klein wenig zu und sag
ihnen wie das hier im Laufe des
Vormittags weitergeht nämlich nach der
Einbringung des Haushalt 2023 der
diskutiert wird zusammen mit dem
Finanzplan des Bundes für die Jahre 2022
bis 26 schließlich dann die allgemeine
finanz-debatte an und wir werden dann
noch folgende
Ressorts heute hier diskutiert hören
nämlich beispielsweise dass der
Ministerin für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend das steht auf der Agenda dann
der Etat für das Ministerium wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
auch da einen durchaus interessantes
Feld weil die Koalition sich ja da fest
vorgenommen hat 400.000 neue Wohnungen
bauen zu lassen digitales und Verkehr
steht heute auch noch auf der Agenda da
ist es aber dann schon fast 15 Uhr 30
wenn das losgehen wird und dann
schließlich ab ungefähr 17 Uhr 15 Umwelt
Naturschutz nicht nukleare Sicherheit
und Verbraucherschutz auch ein Thema das
noch mal eine besondere Brisanz
zusätzlich bekommen hat den sie Hinblick
auf die auf mögliche
Laufzeitverlängerung von zwei
Atomkraftwerken sie haben den diskur die
Entscheidung oder die Pressekonferenz
von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck gestern
war möglicherweise auch bei uns gesehen
schauen wir mal ins Plenum rein dass
sich in diesem Moment erhebt weil
nämlich die Bundestagspräsidentin auf
dem Weg zu ihrem Platz ist und das kann
dann nur für mich auch bedeuten dass ich
mal eben rein gebe
guten Morgen meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen schön sie
wiederzusehen schön sie wohl auch
wiederzusehen die Sitzung ist hier mit
eröffnet sie haben ja auch schon Platz
genommen
bevor wir in unsere
Tagesordnung auch eintreten gibt es eine
amtliche Mitteilung in der fraktionell
wurde vereinbart den Gesetzentwurf zur
Stärkung des Schutzes der Bevölkerung
und insbesondere wohl eine Radler
Personengruppen vor kovet 19 auf
Drucksache 25 73 auch dem
Wirtschaftsausschuss zur mitberatung zu
überweisen sind Sie damit einverstanden
das ist offenkundig der Fall ich sehe
kräftiges nicken dann ist der
Gesetzentwurf zur mitberatung an den
Wirtschaftsausschuss auch überwiesen
ich rufe nun auf unseren
Tagesordnungspunkt 1a und 1b die erste
Beratung des von der Bundesregierung
eingebracht
Entwurfes eines Gesetzes über die
Feststellung des bundeshaushaltsplanes
für das Haushaltsjahr 2023 und die
Beratung des Finanzplans des Bundes 2022
bis 2026
im Rahmen der Haushaltsberatungen sind
für die heutige Aussprache im Anschluss
an die 20-minütige Einbringung des
Haushalts sieben Stunden für Mittwoch
acht Stunden für Donnerstag neun Stunden
und 39 Minuten sowie für Freitag drei
Stunden vorgesehen
ich sehe sie sind auch damit
einverstanden mit diesem ambitionierten
Plan und dann verfahren wir auch so und
dann eröffne ich auch die Aussprache und
das Wort zur Einbringung des Haushaltes
hat der Parlamentarische Staatssekretär
beim Bundesministerium der Finanzen Herr
Dr Florian Tonka
Dankeschön
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zunächst darf ich Sie um
Verständnis bitten dass der
Bundesminister Lindner heute aufgrund
eines Trauerfalls diese Rede nicht
halten kann ich bin den Fraktion sehr
dankbar dass wir die Möglichkeit
bekommen haben mit dem Bundesminister am
Donnerstag über den Haushalt zu sprechen
dafür noch mal ganz herzlichen Dank wir
alle stehen noch unter dem Eindruck der
sehr berührenden und Tiefen Rede von
Staatspräsidenten Isaak Herzog der trotz
der beispiellosen Verbrechen die
deutsche an Juden begangen haben einen
engen gemeinsamen Schulterschluss
Israels und Deutschlands angesichts der
Herausforderungen der Gegenwart und der
Zukunft angeboten hat und ich denke wir
sollten dieses Angebot in Demut und
Dankbarkeit annehmen
wir stehen ohne jede Frage in der
Bundesrepublik und in Europa in der Welt
in einer
Bewährungsprobe wie wir sie lange nicht
mehr erlebt haben wie Pandemie hat Kraft
gekostet physische Kraft soziale Kraft
auch finanzielle Kraft und der russische
Angriff auf die Ukraine hat eine völlig
neue Lage geschossen geschaffen wir
sehen den Einsatz von Energie als Waffe
wir sehen den Einsatz von Hunger als
Waffe wir erleben explodierende
Energiepreise und in Deutschland eine
Inflation im August von
7,9% bei gleichzeitig stark
zurückgehenden Wirtschaftswachstum
vieles ist im Ungewissen und insofern
meine ich war oder sollte der Besuch von
Staatspräsident Herzog und seine Rede
hier heute für uns auch Anlass zu sein
und vielleicht einmal damit
auseinanderzusetzen wie ein Land der
Staat Israel der seit 1948 im Grunde
beständig fast Tag für Tag
herausgefordert wird
der Staatspräsident sprach den Anschlag
an auf das israelische Olympia-Team 1972
und aktuell das iranische Atomprogramm
dieser Staat mit solchen
Bewährungsproben umgeht in Israel ist
das stets gelungen unter auch
schwierigsten Druck von außen eine
vielfältige Gesellschaft eine innovative
eine sehr sehr leistungsfähige
Gesellschaft zu erhalten dort weiß man
und das habe ich mir auch weil ich
selbst letzte Woche noch in Israel war
auch noch mal eindrücklich zeigen lassen
in schwierigen Zeiten ist es am
riskantesten nichts zu tun und alles zu
lassen wie es ist ich glaube das können
wir von Israel lernen auch um selbst mit
dieser Bewährungsprobe und der
Ungewissheiten zu gehen
und eine solche sehr ungewisse Lage die
sich natürlich auch ständig wechselt
ständig wandelt die bewältigt man
dadurch dass wo kurzfristig nötig
gehandelt wird und richtig gehandelt
wird aber man überwindet sie dauerhaft
nur dadurch dass wir die Gesellschaft
modernisieren dass wir die strukturellen
Probleme die bereits vorher vorhanden
waren in der Krise erst recht und
beschleunigt angehen und genau das ist
auch das was wir jetzt in dieser Krise
machen wir brauchen neue Lieferungen als
Ersatz für russische Gaslieferungen zum
Beispiel Flüssiggas wir bauen dafür
entsprechende Terminals und wir lernen
daraus schnellere Planungsprozesse sind
nicht nur bei Flüssiggas wichtig sie
sind auch für die Energiewende wichtig
die Digitalisierung den Wohnungsbau und
die Infrastruktur und deswegen kommt das
und das ist nur einmal wir lernen wir
müssen in Deutschland in der Lage sein
sanktioniertes Vermögen zu erkennen und
auch einzufrieren und wir ziehen daraus
den Schluss dass es dabei auch nicht
bleiben muss sondern dass wir generell
die Geldwäschebekämpfung in Deutschland
auf eine neue Grundlage stellen müssen
so wie es der Bundesfinanzminister in
der letzten Woche vorgeschlagen hat das
ist ein weitergehender Schluss der
dauerhaft Probleme abstellt die vorher
schon da waren und
wir stellen fest es gibt technologische
Abhängigkeiten von Ländern von denen wir
nicht abhängig sein wollen und sein
sollten und wir ziehen daraus den
Schluss wir brauchen eine
start-up-strategie der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist hier wir
brauchen ein
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetzes der
Bundesfinanzminister mit dem
Bundesjustizminister vorgeschlagen hat
um auch und gerade in den
technologiebasierten neuen
Geschäftsfeldern in Deutschland stärker
zu werden und das über den Tag und über
diese Krise hinaus
wir haben sehr viele Handlungsfelder wo
die Modernisierung des Landes angegangen
wird über den Tag und die aktuelle
Krisensituation hinaus und dennoch gibt
es sie und das größte aktuelle Problem
in Deutschland ist ohne jede Frage die
Inflation und ihre Folgen sie
überfordert viele Menschen schlichtweg
in finanzieller Hinsicht sie raubt
Menschen Planungssicherheit
Lebensplanung und damit auch Freiheit
individuelle Freiheit und Inflation
gefährdet unternehmerischen Erfolg
unserer Gesellschaft im Ganzen Inflation
zu bekämpfen muss das oberste Ziel
gerade auch der Finanzpolitik sein und
natürlich
natürlich hat Inflation nie nur eine
Ursache aber es ist wichtig
zuerst an den Ursachen anzusetzen und
dann folgen zu kompensieren und deswegen
ist es wichtig für die Bekämpfung von
Inflation beispielsweise Flüssiggas oder
andere alternative Energiequellen zu
importieren es ist wichtig mit einem
modernen Einwanderungsrecht dafür zu
sorgen dass wir mehr Menschen haben dich
auch am Arbeitsmarkt aktiv sind und die
Engpässe die überall zu spüren sind auch
zu beseitigen genau das geht diese
Koalition an es ist jahrelang nicht
passiert aber es ist nötig
und
auch das hat mit der Bekämpfung von
inflationsursachen zu tun wir sollten
den Handel mit befreundeten Ländern
erleichtern deswegen werden wir das
Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada
ratifizieren und damit einen Beitrag
leisten dafür dass wir auch leichter an
Importe kommen können als bisher
zweitens
der Staat sollte in inflationären
Situationen nicht auch noch mit eigenen
Regeln die Preise nach oben treiben es
ist ohne jede Frage so dass Preise
wirken müssen dass sich Preise bilden
müssen und das Preise auch dazu führen
dass die Gesellschaft bestimmte Dinge
ändern zum Beispiel sparsamer mit
Energie
geht das ist dennoch muss man natürlich
die Frage stellen ist das klug in einer
Situation wo sich Inflation aufbaut und
wir an dem Punkt sind wo sich
entscheidet ob sie bleibt oder ob sie
wieder sinkt in dem Punkt wo es auf
Inflationserwartungen ankommt auch noch
staatlicherseits Preise zu treiben
deswegen haben wir die EEG-Umlage zum
ersten siebten abgeschafft und den
Strompreis damit entlastet deswegen
haben wir beschlossen am Wochenende eine
strompreisbremse die in großen Umfang
und mit einem sozialen Schwerpunkt
Menschen entlasten wird von den hohen
Strompreisen und deswegen haben wir auch
beschlossen die staatliche
co2-bepreisung zu verschieben all das
soll dafür sorgen dass die
Inflationserwartungen jetzt nicht noch
weiter steigen und dabei helfen
Inflation auch wieder in den Griff zu
bekommen
dennoch gibt es sie und deswegen müssen
wir natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass
ihre Folgen
kompensiert werden wobei der Staat ganz
sicher nicht alles kompensieren kann
aber wir haben einen beachtliches Paket
von wenn man alles zusammenzählt über 95
Milliarden Euro in verschiedenen
Schritten dieses Jahr auf den Weg
gebracht das ist äußerst beachtlich und
das zeigt auch wie leistungsfähig dieses
Land ist in dem wir leben es geht dabei
um direkte Hilfen für Menschen die
besonders betroffen sind die besonders
stark unter den steigenden Preisen
Leiden das sind die Empfänger von Hilfen
das sind die Empfänger von Wohngeld das
sind Familien das sind Erwerbstätige
Rentner Pensionäre Studenten und
Familien und ich warne davor zu sagen
weil wir diesen Gruppen mit
unterschiedlichen Instrumenten helfen
das sei die Gießkannen denn es gibt es
gibt gerade auch in der Mittelschicht
viele Menschen die bezahlen ihre
Stromrechnung selber die bezahlen ihre
Gasrechnung selber und die brauchen
jetzt Unterstützung aber es gibt nicht
immer das eine einzige Instrument mit
dem man alle erreichen kann und deswegen
ist es nötig mit mehreren nebeneinander
anzuwenden genau das tun wir weil wir
auch an die Mittelschicht denken die
selbst mit dieser Situation zu
rangekommen muss und
wir werden dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen die Steuern bezahlen nicht
durch die Inflation faktisch in einen
höheren Steuertarif getrieben werden das
ist der Ausgleich der kalten Progression
wenn jemand der bisher 40.000 Euro
verdient hat künftig durch die Inflation
weiterhin 40.000 Euro verdient aber
Kaufkraft für 37.000 Euro hat ist es
nicht richtig im Meer Steuern
abzuverlangen als vorher der bestraft
man die Menschen doppelt indem man
einerseits die mit der Inflation
natürlich leben müssen und auf der
anderen Seite höhere Steuern abverlangt
genau das wollen wir ausgleichen genau
das ist unser faires Angebot an dem
Mittelschicht und
insofern
haben wir uns mit einem wuchtigen Paket
auch den Folgen den Erscheinungen dieser
hohen Inflation gestellt
zu einer Bekämpfung von Inflation gehört
aber auch das Haushalte konsolidiert
werden das ist anders als in Zeiten der
Pandemie wo es richtig war eine
expansive Fiskalpolitik zu betreiben
heute ziemlicher Konsens dass wir heute
keine expansive Fiskalpolitik mehr
benötigen sondern eine planvolle
Rückkehr zu sinkenden Defiziten und auch
das ist zeitenwände denn es ist eine
andere ökonomische Situation als noch in
der Pandemie in Deutschland bedeutet das
dass wir im Jahr 2023 mit diesem
Haushaltsentwurf zur Regelgrenze nach
der Schuldenbremse zurückkehren werden
die Schuldenbremse ist nicht irgendetwas
sie ist auch nicht wie ich in Zeitungen
manchmal lesen darf ein Fetisch
oder irgendetwas ähnliches sondern sie
ist im Kern eine Regel die mit zwei
drittelmehrheit im Bundestag und zwei
Drittel Mehrheit im Bundesrat in unserer
Grundgesetz geschrieben ist und
dementsprechend auch den Respekt
verdient den eine Regel im Grundgesetz
verdient sie ist einzureichen
man kann
politisch dafür argumentieren sie auch
wieder zu ändern aber sie gilt und sie
ist nicht mit bestimmten Worten
respektierlich
respektierlich zu behandeln und ein
Finanzminister der sich der Einhaltung
des Grundgesetzes verpflichtet fühlt
erfüllt nicht mehr und nicht weniger als
seinen Amtszeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und insofern
und insofern ist der Vorschlag der Ihnen
vorliegt dass die Neuverschuldung nach
215,4 Milliarden im Jahr 2021 maximal
138,9 Milliarden in diesem Jahr im
nächsten Jahr auf 17,2 Milliarden
abgesenkt wird das ist ein schwieriger
Schritt das ist auch ein Schritt der mit
Konsolidierungsmaßnahmen verbunden ist
beispielsweise einer stelleneinsparung
von 1,5 Prozent ausgenommen der
Sicherheitsbereich der verbunden ist mit
einer globalen Minderausgabe die alle
Ressorts zu erbringen hat aber es ist
ein notwendiger Schritt denn die
Schuldenbremse hat ja einen Sinn sie
soll zwei Dinge leisten sie soll dafür
sorgen dass heutige Generationen ihre
Herausforderungen nicht in einer Weise
lösen die künftigen Generationen schwer
oder unmöglich macht die Herausforderung
die sich ihnen irgendwann Stellen werden
genauso gut in den Griff zu kriegen wie
wir heute und die Schuldenbremse ist
eine Regel die fundamental darauf
ausgerichtet ist die Handlungsfähigkeit
unseres Staates und damit auch die
Akzeptanz und Stärke unseres Staates zu
erhalten und dir das letzte Jahrzehnt
ist ja ein gutes Beispiel dafür wir sind
aus der Finanzkrise im Jahr 2010 mit
einem Schuldenstand gesamtstaatlich von
etwa 80 Prozent rausgekommen und im Jahr
2019 der Bundeskanzler als damaliger
Finanzminister
hat das direkt und aus der Nähe erlebt
im Jahr 2019 vor der Pandemie haben wir
es geschafft bei
58,9% Schuldenstand zu Landes ist
gelungen in einem Jahrzehnt von 80 auf
unter 60 zu kommen und nur dadurch dass
das passiert ist ist es auch gelungen
dass wir in der Pandemie die
finanziellen Möglichkeiten hatten dann
expansiv zu reagieren der Zusammenhang
ist klar die Schuldenbremse schützt
Handlungsfähigkeit und auch
krisenfähigkeit des Staates in der
Zukunft
und natürlich
und natürlich ist es richtig dass die
Herausforderungen heute multibe sind die
Krisen sind multipel wir haben eine
Pandemie die in einer anderen Phase ist
als noch vor einem Jahr aber die noch da
ist die Aufmerksamkeit erfordert wir
haben die Herausforderung des Krieges
der Inflation und die Aufgabe sehr
schnell auch unseren CO2-Ausstoß
abzusenken plus einen großen
Investitionsbedarf das ist unbestritten
aber keine dieser Herausforderungen
verschwindet in einem Jahr oder in zwei
Jahren es sind alles staatliche
daueraufgaben und deshalb ist es auch
wichtig und nötig diese staatlichen
daueraufgaben auch strukturell in den
Haushalt einzuarbeiten genau darum geht
es jetzt und genau dafür ist der
Haushalt 23 und der mit vorgelegte
Finanzplan auch der richtige Schritt
und eines wird oft auch vergessen die
Schuldenbremse wenn man sieht wenn man
sie aussetzt führt dazu dass man erst
mal mehr ausgeben kann aber es wird auch
dazu dass später mehr getilgt werden
muss und auch das ist ein Argument dafür
wenn wir wissen dass das daueraufgaben
sind dass wir sie früher einhalten dann
müssen wir später weniger tilgen und
haben größere Handlungsspielraum
insofern
insofern ist es wichtig dass wir diese
Regeln jetzt wieder einhalten und ich
will auch sehr deutlich sagen die
Entlastungsmaßnahmen die ich gerade
angesprochen habe die wir gemeinsam am
Wochenende beschlossen haben die glaube
ich eine starke Wirkung auch haben
werden sind mit diesem Ziel vereinbar
wir haben im laufenden Haushaltsjahr
Spielräume dadurch dass wir sparsam
gewirtschaftet haben wir haben höhere
Steuereinnahmen absehbar in diesem Jahr
und auch im nächsten Jahr die wir
zurückgeben können und auch zurückgeben
wollen und wir haben
keine Sorge wir haben bereits Vorsorge
im Regierungsentwurf 2023 geschaffen
auch und gerade für Entlastungsmaßnahmen
die wir nutzen können insofern deckt
nach unserer Auffassung Ecken die
entlass sind die Entlastungen die
beschlossen worden sind mit der
Schuldenbremse mit dem Ziel sie wieder
einzuhalten für den Bund vereinbar ich
will aber auch sehr deutlich sagen mehr
zu tun ist im Bund nicht möglich es ist
jetzt das was wir leisten können und
auch leisten werden
ich möchte
zum Abschluss noch auf einige
Schwerpunkte in diesem Haushalt eingehen
weil auch deutlich ist dass wir in
Krisenzeiten sehr wohl in sehr vielen
Politikfeldern Schwerpunkte setzen und
auch neue Projekte beginnen können die
Schuldenbremse ist weder
Investitions noch innovationsbremse man
sieht das an investitionsetat die
Investitionsausgaben des Bundes bleiben
auf Rekordniveau wir haben mit 51
Milliarden Euro ein sehr sehr hohen Wert
für Investitionen dahinter verbergen
sich natürlich vor allem
Verkehrsinvestitionen wobei mehr Geld in
die Schiene als in die Straße fließt wir
haben Zukunftsprojekte im Bereich
Mikroelektronik von über 4 Milliarden
Euro auch ein Stück Autonomie ein Stück
Unabhängigkeit wir haben hohe
Investitionen im Klima und
transformationsfonds für
Wasserstoffwirtschaft E-Mobilität und
auch Gebäudesanierung wo wir stark
steigende Nachfrage angesichts der
aktuellen Situation beobachten
Deutschland investiert der Bund
investiert und kommt damit seinen
Aufgaben und Verpflichtungen auch in
wir haben im Bereich Bildung und
Forschung ebenfalls wachsende plafonds
natürlich ist das etwas was auch gerade
für die Zukunft unseres Landes sehr sehr
wichtig ist wir werden insgesamt im
Finanzplanungszeitraum etwa vier
Milliarden Euro mehr für Bildung und
Forschung ausgeben können als noch in
der vorherigen Finanzplanung angesetzt
zum Beispiel für Leistungsverbesserung
beim Bafög und eine Stärkung der
missionsorientierten Forschung wir geben
Geld aus es selbstverständlich auch für
die Stärkung des sozialen Zusammenhalts
wir werden im sozialen Wohnungsbau
beispielsweise den Ländern steigende
Mittel zur Verfügung stellen um diese
Aufgabe auch wahrnehmen zu können und
ihren Beitrag leisten zu können für die
für das Ziel 400.000 Wohnungen davon
100.000 öffentlich geförderte pro Jahr
zu realisieren wir werden die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung weiterhin
mit großen Summen unterstützen 112
Milliarden Euro sind das im kommenden
Jahr das wird ansteigen bis zum Jahr
2026 fast 128,8 Milliarden Euro und wir
werden wir werden weil die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung
in einem Zustand übergeben worden ist
der ausgesprochen um es nicht
auszudrücken reformbedürftig
auch seitens des Bundeshaushalts
zusätzlich noch mal zwei Milliarden Euro
als Zuschuss und eine Million Jahre der
Euro als Darlehen in ein gutes
Gesundheitssystem stecken das sind Dinge
die wir machen weil sie richtig sind
weil sie den Alltag der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger betreffen und die sind auch
möglich auch in den Zeiten die wir
momentan haben wir haben ansonsten
selbstverständlich auch riesige
Herausforderungen im internationalen
Bereich wir haben uns darauf verständigt
für die internationale Klimafinanzierung
2023 vier Milliarden Euro beizutragen
wir haben auch die sogenannten oder
Maßnahmen also die Maßnahmen für
öffentliche
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
einschließlich humanitärer Hilfe
fortgeschrieben auf über 22 Milliarden
Euro Deutschland wird auch im kommenden
Jahr nach den USA weltweit der größte
Geber sein und nach allem was wir
voraussagen können werden wir auch die
0,7 Prozent oder Quote die das Ziel sind
das in diesem Bereich gilt auch
einhalten zusammen mit dem
Haushaltsentwurf den wir hier vorgelegt
haben das ist ein wichtiges Signal denn
ich habe angesprochen Hunger als Waffe
ist er ist auch ein Teil dessen was
Putin macht und insofern sind wir hier
gefordert uns auch entsprechend
einzubringen so wie es Deutschlands
wir werden nachdem wir
im Frühjahr das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr beschließen konnten auch den
Verteidigungsetat fortschreiben mit 50,1
Milliarden Euro das ist übrigens etwa
drei Milliarden mehr als die letzte
Finanzplanung der Regierung Merkel für
dieses Jahr eingeplant hatte drei
Milliarden mehr
Einzelplan 14 für die Bundeswehr und
eine Zeitenwende Herr Kollege frei ich
dachte jetzt sind sie zufrieden denn sie
haben ja immer gesagt die Bundeswehr
soll mehr bekommen und wir geben
immerhin mehr als 3 Milliarden mehr als
sie noch vor einem Jahr vorgeschlagen
haben ich finde das ist eigentlich ein
ziemlich guter Schritt
zumal die
finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen ja nicht
einfacher geworden sind in der Zeit das
Sondervermögen die 100 Milliarden Euro
werden
schrittweise natürlich abschließend in
dem Maße in dem auch Lieferungen von
entsprechenden militärischen Geräten
erfolgen wir rechnen damit dass das
zusätzlich zum Einzelplan 14 nächstes
Jahr 8,5 Milliarden Euro etwa betragen
wird man muss aber sagen der besondere
nutzen diese sondervermögenslichter
gerade darin dass die Bundeswehr mit dem
Budget von 100 Milliarden Euro sofort
planen kann und sofort parallel
beschaffen kann und insofern sind wir
sehr froh dass wir diese Möglichkeit
haben jetzt auf einen Schlag und damit
auch systematisch die Streitkräfte so zu
modernisieren wie es auch vorher schon
richtig gewesen wäre liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es ist
ohne jede Frage
herausfordernde Umgebung es ist auch
nicht so dass es für alle diese Themen
leichte Lösungen geben würde oder dass
das hier jemand so vortragen würde es
gibt Auseinandersetzungen zu führen es
gibt auch Dinge abzuwägen dieser
Haushalt bringt sehr viele Ziele die wir
verfolgen Krisenbewältigung aber auch
den Blick in die Zukunft Investitionen
soziales Infrastruktur zusammen er ist
ein gut eine gute Grundlage für die
parlamentarische Beratungen davon bin
ich überzeugt selbstverständlich gerade
in der jetzigen Umgebung wird es auch
noch Dinge geben die geändert die
eingearbeitet werden müssen
einschließlich der Beschlüsse des
letzten Wochenendes zu Entlastungen das
ist selbstverständlich aber ich meine
der Haushalt zeigt dieses Land hat
enorme Ressourcen wenn dieses Land es
schafft seinen startklug einzusetzen
seine staatlichen mittelflug einzusetzen
und gleichzeitig auch die Kraft der
Gesellschaft vertraut dann können wir
auch diese Bewährungsprobe in der wir
sind meistern so ähnlich meine ich
würden auch die Menschen in Israel mit
dieser Situation umgehen machen wir uns
das zu eigen und nehmen wir diese
Aufgaben an ich danke Ihnen sehr
herzlich
Florian Tonka parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär beim
Bundesfinanzminister hat den
Bundeshaushalt 2023 hier mit eingebracht
übrigens vor dem vor zwei Minuten noch
komplett versammelten Bundeskabinett
jetzt hat sie gerade in den letzten zwei
Minuten noch die eine und andere
Verschiebung bzw Vertretung gegeben auch
der Bundeskanzler ist da und der erste
Redner aus der Opposition zu diesem
Bundeshaushalt ist Matthias Middelberg
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
Unionsfraktion
Herrn Minister Lindner unsere Westen
Wünsche übermitteln wir haben vollstes
Verständnis für ihn und wünschen ihm
alles Gute
zum Haushaltsentwurf 2023 insgesamt
verdient dieser Entwurf Kritik und zwar
sehr deutliche Kritik ich will aber
einen Punkt hervorheben in dem ich den
Entwurf auch ausdrücklich loben will und
zwar ist das das Ziel Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse das haben sie selber Herr
Tonka angesprochen dass das von manchen
für einen Fetisch gehalten wird
denselben Begriff habe ich mir hier in
meinem Rede Entwurf auch notiert ja nur
das müssen sie natürlich mit ihren
eigenen Leuten in ihrer eigenen
Koalition ausmachen das müssen sie mit
Herrn Mütze nicht diskutieren mit Frau
esken mit Frau Paus also vielleicht
unterhalten sich mit denen noch mal
darüber was die Schuldenbremse
eigentlich bedeutet denn das haben sie
hier ganz vernünftig erklärt und in der
nullzinsphase kann man da vielleicht
noch drüber lächeln in der aktuellen
Phase in der wir für unsere Kredite
wieder Geld bezahlen müssen nämlich
Zinsen werden uns in jedem Folgejahr
dann diese Zinsen fehlen mit denen wir
hätten Weg gestalten können für 100
Milliarden die sie jetzt neu aufnehmen
und sie nehmen im laufenden Jahr 140
Milliarden neue Schulden auf für diese
100 Milliarden die sie beispielsweise
neu aufnehmen fehlen ihm in jedem Jahr
1,5 Milliarden die sie für Zinsen zahlen
müssen das ist genau der Betrag den Sie
für das Nahverkehrsticket jetzt
aufwenden wollen jedes Jahr das zeigt
wie wichtig die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse ist denn sie würden sich
in Zukunft wenn sie es nicht einhalten
ihre eigenen Handlungsmöglichkeiten ab
dann können Sie nämlich Dinge wie
Nahverkehrsticket und anderes nicht mehr
bezahlen das sieht man jetzt schon das
sieht man jetzt schon an ihrer
Finanzplanung im letzten Jahr haben wir
für Zinsen 4 Milliarden aufwenden müssen
für die gesamte bundesschuld in diesem
Jahr rechnet ihr Minister mit 16
Milliarden und im nächsten Jahr mit fast
30 Milliarden und das Zeig wie ihnen die
Spielräume verengt werden wenn sie
weiter Schulden machen deswegen sage ich
Ihnen
Inflation es wirklich die schlimmste und
das haben sie auch zu Recht gesagt die
schlimmste soziale Ungerechtigkeit es
trifft kleine Einkommen und kleine
Renten und die Bekämpfung der Inflation
geht am besten indem sie keine Schulden
machen indem sie die Schuldenbremse
einhalten die Schuldenbremse ist eine
Frage der Nachhaltigkeit der
Inflationsbekämpfung und Schuldenbremse
einhalten ist sozial gerechte Politik
ihnen gelingt es im nächsten Jahr die
Schuldenbremse allerdings nur
einzuhalten weil sie die über Jahre von
Wolfgang Schäuble aufgebaute
asylrücklage praktisch in einem Jahr
verbraten von den 48 Milliarden
verplanen sie allein im nächsten Jahr
über 40 Milliarden nur deshalb gelingt
ihn die Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
nachhaltig ist das nicht
besonders dramatisch sind ihre
unzureichenden Ansätze im Bereich der
Sozialversicherung wir haben
rekordbeschäftigung in diesem Land wir
haben rekordsteuereinnahmen und trotzdem
sind wir nicht in der Lage bei dieser
ich sag mal wirklich guten
wirtschaftlichen Situationen unsere
Sozialversicherungen zu finanzieren wir
können die Rente daraus nicht bezahlen
wir können die Krankenversicherung nicht
mehr bezahlen wir können auch die
Pflegeversicherung daraus nicht
finanzieren
wir haben selber in dem Thema ich sage
das ganz offen gerade beim Thema Rente
Dinge auch geschoben als Union ich sage
das ganz offen der Unterschied ist nur
wir haben mit dem Thema keinen Wahlkampf
gemacht ihr Bundeskanzler der jetzt
leider nicht mehr unter uns ist hat
dieses Thema als Wahlkampfthema verkauft
er hat sich Plakatieren lassen als
Kanzler für sichere Renten wenn wir uns
jetzt ansehen was sie bisher in diesem
Bereich geleistet auch nur vereinbart
haben in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag dann
ist das genau gar nichts sie haben nur
Ziele festgeschrieben sie wollen das
Rentenalter stabil halten sie wollen das
Rentenniveau stabil halten und die
Beiträge sollen stabil bleiben wie sie
das leisten wollen schreiben Sie an
keiner Stelle das ist extrem unglaubhaft
und es ist noch unglaubhafter wenn sie
sich die Altersentwicklung in diesem
Land ansehen und wenn Sie sehen dass
bald die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge dann
in die Rente gehen dann wird das gesamte
System zusammenbrechen und dafür Herr
Kindler haben sie diese Vorsorge
betroffen das ist die Wirklichkeit res
pekt ihr Kanzler hat von Respekt
gesprochen im Wahlkampf ich sage ihnen
Respekt wäre wenn er sich dieses großen
Thema Sicherung der Alterssicherung mal
endlich annehmen
Thema Thema Entlastungspaket das haben
sie ja diese Woche auch richtig schön
medienwirksam am Sonntag verkauft und
sie schreiben dann in diesem Papier was
sie dazu veröffentlicht haben die
begrenzten finanziellen Spielräume
erfordern erhebliche Anstrengungen aller
drei Koalitionspartner und aller
Ressorts dass sie da viele Anstrengungen
hatten glaube ich ihnen sogar nur der
Satz macht den Eindruck sie hätten jetzt
mal wirklich im Haushalt Umschichtungen
oder schmerzhafter Einschränkungen
vorgenommen also sie hätten zeitenwände
wirklich umgesetzt das haben sie 0 und
was sie jetzt zurückverteilen über
Entlastung das ist das was sie den
Leuten vorher über Steuern aus der
Tasche gezogen haben das ist die
Wirklichkeit wir haben in diesem Jahr
durch die enorm gestiegenen Preise das
kann doch jeder der Tank sehen die
Preise sind enorm nach oben gegangen und
wenn sie darauf jetzt 19% Umsatzsteuer
rechnen nimmt der Staat natürlich irre
viel mehr an Umsatzsteuern ein sie haben
bis Ende Juli erste sieben Monate schon
30 Milliarden insgesamt eingenommen
davon steht die Hälfte dem Bund zu
Jahresende werden es 50 Milliarden für
den Gesamtstaat sein 24 Milliarden für
den Bund über die kalte Progression die
Sie im nächsten Jahr ausgleichen wollen
aber in diesem Jahr einfach mal so
einkassieren das ist nämlich die
Wirklichkeit nehmen sie nochmal 10
Milliarden nur beim Bund ein das ist
reichlich mehr zusammengerechnet als die
32 Milliarden die Herr Lindner groß
verkauft als der Anteil des Bundes am
Entlastungspaket also das ist nichts mit
wirklicher Entlastung sondern das ist
linke Tasche rechte Tasche und zum Thema
gasumlage
hat ihr Bundeskanzler gesagt mit diesem
Schritt die Absenkung der Mehrwertsteuer
von 19 auf 7 entlasten wir die Gaskunden
insgesamt deutlich stärker als die
Mehrbelastung die durch die gasumlage
entsteht an diesem Satz stimmt genau gar
nichts überhaupt nicht die Leute zahlen
jetzt die Gasverbraucher zahlen die
gasumlage jetzt oben drauf und weil sich
der Gaspreis jetzt schon vor drei oder
vervierfacht hat ist doch klar dass
selbst bei abgesunkener Mehrwertsteuer
sie dann auf den dreifach höheren Betrag
auch bei gesenkter Mehrwertsteuer mehr
Mehrwertsteuer im Ergebnis zahlen würden
ist doch ganz einfach das kann jeder
Schwachkopf rechnen wenn sie aber
wirklich wenn Sie eine Gasrechnung
vorher von 1000 Euro hatten und haben
darauf 19% gezahlt dann haben sie 190
Euro bezahlt an Steuern wenn Sie jetzt
die dreifach höhere Gasrechnung haben
von 3000 Euro und Zahlen darauf sieben
dann zahlen Sie jetzt 210 Euro sie
belasten die Leute noch zusätzlich was
ihr Kanzler gesagt deshalb ist absoluter
Schwachsinn das muss man mal so deutlich
sagen ich weiß nicht der hat wirklich
nicht nur überrascht durch seine
Erinnerungslücken in den letzten Monaten
sondern jetzt hat er auch noch Probleme
beim Rechnen vielleicht helfen Sie ihm
damals
Ihr Paket kommt viel zu spät den ganzen
Sommer über haben sie verplempert durch
Streitereien und durch unendlichen Zank
in ihrer Koalition und sie haben eben
gesprochen was kann man tun um die
Inflation zu bekämpfen ja gerade beim
Thema Energie kann man an die
Angebotsseite denken was die FDP ja
offensichtlich auch tut
lobenschwerterweise ihr gerade
entlaufener Wirtschaftsminister tut das
leider nicht wir würden uns freuen wenn
er hier noch zuhören würde denn er ist
der hauptbetroffene diesen Stresstest
den er Habeck da veranstaltet hat das
ist doch völliger Blödsinn der hat nur
getestet ob die Netzstabilität durch den
Betrieb dieser Kraftwerke der drei
Kernkraftwerke die noch laufen gesichert
ist darum alleine geht es doch gar nicht
er hätte den Stresstest auch machen
müssen im Hinblick darauf wie wirkt es
sich wirtschaftlich aus nämlich auf den
Strompreis wie wirkt es sich aus auf das
Thema Gas sparen das wären doch die
relevanten Fragen gewesen die Leute mit
denen ich im Wahlkreis zu tun habe
Mittelständler Bäckerei in Einzelhändler
Stahlunternehmen dass ich letzte Woche
besuchen kommen Sie bitte zum
Schlussrechnungen die neuen ihre
Angebote vorgelegt da geht es um Strom
da geht es um das 10 bis 12-fache des
Strompreises Herr habex sagt wir hätten
keinen Stromproblem doch wir haben eins
er muss sich da ganz zügig korrigieren
Matthias Mittelberg für die
Unionsfraktion naturgemäß nur begrenzt
einverstanden mit dem Haushaltsentwurf
23 und auch nicht mit vielen Punkten des
entlastungspakets vom Wochenende und das
macht er teilweise mit drastischen
Worten empathischen zugewandte Wahrheit
zu Beginn da hat er noch mal darauf
verwiesen dass Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister heute nicht hier
sein kann wegen eines privaten
Trauerfalls in der Familie nächster
Redner hier am Pult in dieser
allgemeinen Finanz
Rohde der Haushälter der SPD-Fraktion
der Ton ihrer Rede hat in Teilen an eine
andere Fraktion in diesem Haus erinnert
ich hoffe dass das nicht Standard wird
und um vielleicht auch das noch mal der
Beginn ihrer Rede wo sie über
Zinsbelastungen Schulden gesprochen
haben der wäre ja gut gewesen wenn Sie
eine komplett neue Fraktion im Deutschen
Bundestag gewesen wären die noch nie
Regierungsverantwortung hat dieser Staat
hat 1,5 Millionen Schulden sie haben die
meiste Zeit regiert wenn Sie mit dem
Finger auf andere zeigen zeigen
mindestens vier Finger zurück liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gab in
den letzten Tagen eine gute Nachricht
die Füllstände unserer Gasspeicher haben
die wichtige Marke von 85% erreicht das
ist nur möglich gewesen weil die
Regierung in den letzten Monaten
besonderen reagiert hat und nicht dem
Aktionismus einiger verfallen ist die im
März schon alle Gasleitungen nach Osten
dicht machen wollen uns würden
Gigawattstunden an Stroh an Gas fehlen
das wäre fatal für dieses Land gewesen
ich bin dieser Bundesregierung dankbar
dass sie das Problem nicht multipliziert
hat vor dem wir stehen und so besonder
reagiert hat Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich glaube wir alle jede Bürgerin jeder
Bürger hätte sich ein bisschen Ruhe nach
der Pandemie gewünscht wir alle hätten
uns gewünscht dass nach den zwei sehr
intensiven Krisenjahren jetzt ruhigere
Zeiten eintreten aber mal wieder hat uns
die Realität neu konfrontiert und ich
glaube wir sollten an diesem Punkt auch
zurückgucken wie wir die letzten Krisen
bewältigt haben
2008/2009 ist dieses Land in eine große
Finanz- und Wirtschaftskrise geraten und
es ist nicht aus dieser Krise
rausgekommen weil der Staat gefragt hat
wer kann das denn Problem denn lösen ist
jemand bereit ist anzugehen sondern weil
der Staat selbst das Heft des Handelns
in die Hand genommen hat weil wir das
Kurzarbeitergeld ausgewiesen haben weil
wir die Einlagen der sparen weil wir die
Spareinlagen sichergestellt haben damals
hat uns ein starker Staat aus dieser
Krise geholfen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und als
2020 die corona-pandemie über uns
hineingebrochen ist hat der Staat wieder
nicht gefragt wer kann uns denn helfen
wer handelt denn das Arbeitsplätze und
Wirtschaft erhalten bleiben sondern ist
zwar wieder ein starker Start der
gehandelt hat der Rettungspakete noch
nie da gewesener Größenordnung gestört
hat der Kurzarbeitergeld mobilisiert hat
und wieder war es ein starker Staat der
uns durch diese Krise gebracht hat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
was uns durch die letzten Krisen
gebracht hat das muss auch Blaupause für
diese Krise sein ich sage auch für die
Fraktion der SPD wir brauchen jetzt
wieder einen starken Start der die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht alleine
lässt nur gemeinsam kommen wir stark
durch diese Krise liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir brauchen jetzt einen Staat der wie
auch in den letzten beiden Krisen bereit
des Jobs und Arbeitsplätze zu sichern
aber eben auch einen der bereit ist den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern bei den
explodierenden Energiepreisen zur Seite
zu stehen und genau das tun wir in den
letzten Monaten genau das tun wir seit
Kriegsbeginn und genau das hat die
Koalition am Wochenende mit dem nächsten
Entlastungspaket vorgelegt wir haben
erneut Direktzahlungen vereinbart an die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner an die
Studierende um zumindest einen Teil der
Mehrkosten aufzufangen wir nehmen
Familien in den Blick durch ein höheres
Kindergeld und durch einen höheren
Kinderzuschlag ein wichtiges Signal an
alle Familien in diesem Land wir zweiten
wir weiten massiv das Wohngeld aus wir
machen das kurzfristig aber auch
langfristig angelehnt um eben abzuwenden
dass Menschen eine existenzbedrohende
Situation kommt die jetzt schon sehr
knapp dran sind das ist auch ein
wichtiges Signal eines starken eines
handelnden Staates liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und ich
finde die Debatte um die CO2-Abgabe die
einige Wissenschaftler gerade führen
auch sehr spannend wir haben gesagt die
CO2-Abgabe ist dafür da eine
Lenkungswirkung zu entfalten aber in
Zeiten immens hoher Energiepreise ist es
richtig zu sagen die Erhöhung setzen wir
aus die verschieben wir erst mal weil
die Preise schon so hoch sind und wenn
dann Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler von einem fatalen Signal
sprechen und die Lenkungswirkung als
Abhandenkommen ansehen dann frage ich
mich in welcher Wirklichkeit die Leben
jetzt geht es darum Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu entlasten liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und wir sind bereit als Bund auch wenn
es verfassungsrechtlich nicht unsere
Aufgabe ist ein nachfolgeticket für das
9 euro-ticket mitzufinanzieren aber an
der Stelle liegt die Betonung auf
mitzuffinanzieren wir sind bereit 1,5
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung zu stellen
und ich hoffe dass die Länder damit
machen und dass wir gemeinsam ein
erfolgreiches Nachfolge Ticket auf dem
Weg bringen
wir haben uns darauf verständigt auch
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgebern
gemeinsam mit Arbeitnehmerinnen und
nehme eine Verständigung möglich zu
machen die eine Einmalzahlung möglich
macht die dann komplett Steuer und
abgabefrei ist auch das ist ein
wichtiges Signal und ja das alles wird
Geld kosten das alles wird den
Bundeshaushalt belasten das alles wird
die Länderhaushalte belasten das alles
wird den Klima und transformationsform
belasten da kommt eine große
finanzierungsaufgabe auf uns zu aber ich
finde es gilt genau dasselbe was 2008
und 2009 gegolten hat es gilt genau
dasselbe was 2020 2021 gegolten hat wenn
wir jetzt nichts tun würden dann würde
es für den Staat am Ende wesentlich
teurer werden und dann würde es auch für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wesentlich
teurer werden wir müssen jetzt handeln
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
wir schieben die Finanzierung eben nicht
in die Zukunft ich meine wir erleben das
ja gerade am Strommarkt da ist aufgrund
der der Marktmechanismus gerade mag
Mechanismen gerade eine Situation dass
der Strompreis deutlich nach oben geht
aber Unternehmen die Billigstrom zum
Beispiel aus Erneuerbaren einkaufen
können
milliardengewinde und Umsätze machen und
wir sagen jetzt eben nicht wir
kompensieren das indem der bunte
einspringt und neue Schulden macht die
dann irgendwann ab 2028 oder so von den
dann nachfolgenden Generationen bezahlt
werden müssen sondern uns ist klar wer
zufallsgewinne hat in einer Krise der
muss sie auch zur Verfügung stellen
damit der Stromkreis nicht durch die
Decke geht auch das ist soziale
Verantwortung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und es gehört auch zur Wahrheit und das
ist gerade zu Recht angesprochen worden
die Inflation treibt natürlich auch die
umsatzsteuereinnahmen des Bundes und ich
glaube die Menschen haben ein sehr
feines Gefühl dafür ob wir das was wir
von anderen fordern nämlich dass sie
bereit sind ihre übergewinde wieder
zurückzugeben ob wir auch selbst dazu
bereit sind deshalb ist es richtig dass
der Bund sagt das was wir an
Mehrwertsteuer Mehreinnahmen haben das
was wir quasi als zufallsgewinner als
übergewinner haben das geben wir auch an
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zurück und
ich finde wenn ich jetzt den einen oder
anderen Ministerpräsidenten höre zum
Beispiel Herrn wüst aus NRW das gilt
auch für die Landeshaushalt die kriegen
nämlich 52 Prozent dieser Einnahmen und
ich finde auch die haben eine
Verantwortung an dieser Stelle
der Bundeshaushalt ist im Volumen 50
Milliarden Euro geringer als im letzten
Jahr und wenn andere regiert hätten und
das getan hätten was sie im letzten
Haushalt gefordert haben nämlich die
Rücklage komplett aufzulösen dann hätten
wir jetzt eine Situation dass es nicht
50 Milliarden wäre sondern es wären 90
Milliarden nur weil wir über Jahre dafür
gesorgt haben dass wir die Rücklage dann
einsetzen können wenn wir die
Schuldenbremse wieder einhalten schaffen
wir es eine Abbruchkante eine soziale
Abbruchkante in diesem Land verhindern
das ist vorausschauende Politik in den
letzten Jahren gewesen und das zahlt
sich heute aus liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir stehen vor Haushaltsverhandlungen
die erneut von großen Unsicherheiten
behaftet sind wir wissen nicht wie sich
die Zinsen in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten entwickelt werden wir wissen
nicht gesichert wie sich die Inflation
wie sich das Wirtschaftswachstum unseres
Landes entwickeln wird wir wissen nicht
was sich aus den arbeitsmaß der
Arbeitsmarktsituation heraus in den
Sozialversicherungssystemen abspielen
wird wir werden eventuell auf weitere
Dinge reagieren müssen zum Beispiel auch
im internationalen Kontext und deshalb
sage ich auch für unsere Fraktion wir
sind bereit in den nächsten Monat in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen auch auf die sich
verändernden Ausgangslagen zu reagieren
am Ende muss die Botschaft sein wir
lassen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht
alleine nur gemeinsam sind wir stark in
dieser Krise und das muss über allem
stehen in den nächsten Wochen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
primäre Aufgabe ist es dieses Land gut
durch die Krise zu bekommen dass es
Schwerpunkt der nächsten Wochen und
Monaten und dafür setzen wir uns ein
vielen Dank
Dennis Rohde der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte die die
Debatten Tage im Deutschen Bundestag zum
Bundeshaushalt 23 eröffnet da sehen und
hören wir jetzt Peter Böhringer den
haushaltspolitischen Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin wir sprechen heute über
einen vermutlich nur kurzlebigen
Haushaltsentwurf 2023 falls er
tatsächlich im November so wie geplant
verabschiedet werden sollte steuert der
Finanzminister trotz illegaler Rücklagen
von über 200 Milliarden Euro und trotz
wir haben es ja eben gehört
inflationsbedingte gewaltiger Steuer
Mehreinnahmen zu lassen der deutschen
Bürger auf einen Nachtragshaushalt 23 zu
es ist heute eigentlich schon relativ
wahrscheinlich warum natürlich wegen der
energiekostenexplosion die dümmste
Energiepolitik der Welt führt in
Deutschland heute zu den höchsten
Stromkosten der Welt
sie ist sowohl gegenüber den Bürgern als
auch gegenüber der deutschen Industrie
absolut verantwortungslos die
preiskurven spotten ihrer Beschreibung
und werden zu Massen Insolvenzen und
Verarmung führen
die Regierung ist dabei uns nicht nur
frieren zu lassen sondern unsere
Wirtschaft zu zerstören 50 Prozent des
Erdgases gehen in zentrale Industrien
Düngemittel Nahrungsmittel Produktion
Verpackungsindustrie Metallverarbeitung
schon heute wandern jeden Tag Betriebe
ab oder
geben auf etwa die SWK Stickstoffe
priesteritz ohne deren AdBlue für LKWs
könnten sogar Logistikketten brechen die
Folgen wären verheerend
wir müssen sogar über Strommangel
sprechen die Ampel wird im Winter in
einem großen Experiment mit uns als
Versuchskaninchen versuchen durch
kontrollierte teilabschaltungen
Blackouts zu vermeiden dann wären wir
auf dem Niveau eines Entwicklungslandes
angekommen
Energie Energie ist das Lebensblut einer
modernen Wirtschaft Ideologen und
ignoranten die von Technologie und
Ökonomie keine Ahnung haben denn ist es
in 40 Jahren fehlgeleiteter
Energiepolitik gelungen die deutsche
Wirtschaft an den Rand dieser
Katastrophe zu führen dabei übrigens
über 30 Jahre CDU geführt
die deutschen Sparkassen rechnen damit
das schon bald 60% der deutschen ihre
gesamten Einkünfte oder mehr für die
reine Lebenshaltung aufwenden oder
einsetzen müssen das wird die
Lebensplanung all dieser Menschen völlig
verändern Armut ohne Spielraum für
eigene Lebensgestaltung ist schrecklich
spätestens im nächsten Jahr wird ein
erneut die schönen Obergrenze der
Verfassung gerissen faktisch Herr
Staatssekretär tun sie das auch in
diesem Jahr bereits mit diesem
Haushaltsentwurf der Bundesrechnungshof
hat es ihnen eben noch mal vorgerechnet
ich habe das schon vor über Monaten
getan sie reißen sie um das Vierfache
aber da fällt heute die Zeit dafür es
ist also schlichtweg nicht wahr worüber
sie minutenlang geredet haben dass die
letzten Endes die Schuldengrenze
einhalten wenn es zum Nachtragshaushalt
kommt sowieso nicht mehr
ja und dann mal sehen welche
Notsituation diesmal dann als Begründung
herhalten muss vermutlich wird es ja
just jener energienotstand sein den sie
selbst herbeigeführt haben denen es ohne
die Irre Energie und Geopolitik der
Ampel und der groko so nie gegeben hätte
den Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie den
reinen ideologischen Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien die verkündeten
Sanktionen und die Waffenlieferungen
gegen deutsche Interessen die im Winter
kommende Mangelverwaltung und das
inflationsdesaster sind Politik gemacht
und sie gehen auf das Konto aller
Altparteien denn auch die cdu/csu wird
nicht so tun können als habe es den
Merkel schon Ausstiegsbeschluss aus der
modernen sicheren und heute fast
rückstandsfreien Kernenergie nicht
gegeben und die Union trägt auch
Verantwortung für den fatalen green Deal
für diese fatalen Fehlentscheidungen
gegen Kohle gegen Öl-
die Verknappung der CO2-Zertifikate war
politisch gewollt der Preis pro Tonne
lag schon vor dem Angriff Putins auf die
Ukraine bei über 90 Euro
Experte Professor Fahrenholz spricht ist
klar aus der Ausstieg aus Kernenergie
und Kohle funktionierte nur weil wir im
Hintergrund immer mehr russisches Gas
zuführten lange vor dem ukrainekrieg
sonst wäre die Energiewende schon vor
Jahren gescheitert wenn die Pipelines
nicht schnellstmöglich wieder Gas
transportieren sind in Deutschland 6
Millionen Arbeitsplätze gefährdet wir
sind dabei unsere Industrie zu zerstören
wenn sie noch Stream und damit
unschlagbar günstiges Pipeline Gas nicht
nutzen wird genau das passieren eine
Regierung die sagt kein Gas aus Russland
obwohl just ihre eigene Politik diese
Abhängigkeit von Russland herbeigeführt
hat grüne Politik ist entweder weltfremd
oder gar vorsätzlich gegen Deutschland
gerichtet ja wenn ich inzwischenrufe
höre natürlich ist es grüne Politik
gewesen es war grüne Politik denn es war
ökonomisch sinnvoll die in flatterstrom
aus den erneuerbaren Energien zu
kompensieren mit dem einzig möglichen
das war da die Gaskraftwerke die schnell
rauf und runter regelbar sind nur so
deshalb sind sie persönlich alle
zumindest sobald sie jetzt in der
Regierung sind aber damals ja auch schon
Einfluss hatten mit Schuld daran an
dieser Geschichte
ja am Ende profitiert Russland sogar
noch von Sanktionen die ampelregierung
verzichtet zum Beispiel auf langfristige
kohle-lieferungen aus Russland die einen
Bruchteil des heutigen Preises gekostet
hätten man verzichtet in der jetzigen
Situation darauf und Russland kann die
Kohle anderweitig zum achtfachen Preis
verkaufen dabei hat Russland bereits
heute die weltbeste Handelsbilanz und so
wollen sie Russland in die Knie zwingen
es ist irre
falls Sie ernsthaft in wenigen Monaten
die letzten drei dann noch verbliebenen
deutschen Kernkraftwerke abschalten dann
wäre das gleichbedeutend mit dem Abriss
von 10.000 Windrädern eigentlich sogar
noch mehr denn die Windräder liefern ja
nur flatterstrom und auch das deshalb
braucht man noch mehr Reservekapazität
und auch das ist natürlich
unverantwortbar
und die EU in ihrer unendlichen
Boshaftigkeit verschärft die
Preisspirale bei Energie sogar noch sie
zieht ihr absurdes Programm fit for
fifty five nicht zurück ein vorzulassen
Deutschlands mit dem die grüne
co2-religion in der ganzen EU
durchgesetzt werden soll deutsche
Steuerzahler sollen die
energieumstellung in anderen EU-Ländern
subventionieren bei deutschen
Verbrauchern dürfen sich die
energiepreisrechnungen offensichtlich
verfünffachen das stört die Ampel nicht
in der EU stört es sie
tja und Herr Lindner auch in Abwesenheit
diese Mahnung an sie sie haben die
Interessen der deutschen zu vertreten
der deutsche Haushalt kann es nicht
verkraften wenn sie nicht endlich die
Energieprobleme ursächlich angehen
ursächlich und eben nicht symptomatisch
wie wir es jetzt am Wochenende wieder
gehört haben die volkswirtschaftlichen
Mehrkosten für Energie gegenüber 2020
das ist das Vergleichsjahr wir tragen
bei heutigen future-preisen 250
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr das ist die auf
Basis der
des jetzigen future-preises
60 Prozent eines Bundeshaushalts dagegen
verblasst jede gasumlage das ist
eigentlich eine Nebenkriegsschauplatz
das stimmt sogar das deutsche kreditbuch
nicht der Steuerzahler nicht mehr man
kann diese Summen nicht mehr mit
entlastungspaketen auffangen hier hilft
nur ein Regierungswechsel und endlich
eine rationale Energiepolitik die es
langfristig nur mit der AFD geben kann
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss frau
Präsidentin handeln sie einmal für
Deutschland und wenn das bedeutet diese
rot-grüne Regierung sofort zu verlassen
nun denn es ist besser nicht zu regieren
als falsch zu regieren herzlichen
Peter Böhringer haushaltspolitischer
Sprecher der afd-fraktion mit seiner
Sicht auf Energiepolitik und Russland im
Besonderen
Sven Christian Kindler ist der nächste
Redner kommt aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen und ist ein weiterer
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher gewesen
bin jetzt seit 2009 Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss und ich glaube alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Haushaltsausschuss wissen das wären die
schwersten Haushaltsberatungen seit
Jahrzehnten das liegt daran dass einfach
wir verschiedene Krisen gleichzeitig
auftreten wir haben die brutalen
schrecklichen Angriffskrieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine mit der massiven
Inflation die daraus folgt bei Gas und
auch bei Öl wir sehen dass es
international schwere Verwerfungen hat
Putin Hunger als Waffe einsetzt
gleichzeitig haben wir immer noch eine
Gesundheitskrise durch die
corona-pandemie und wir haben den
vierten Hitzesommer in fünf Jahren
erlebt die schlimmste Dürre in Europa
seit 50 Jahren und all das hat massive
Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft auf
die Wirtschaft und auch auf diesen
Haushalt für uns in der Koalition in
diesem parlamentarischen
Haushaltsverhandlungen ist klar wir
stellen uns diesen Krisen entschlossen
wir ducken uns nicht weg sondern wir
gehen die Probleme entschlossen an
und deswegen ist es richtig und gut dass
der Koalitionsausschuss am Wochenende
ein großes Paket beschlossen hat trotz
aller politischen Unterschiede die auch
normal sind eine Demokratie hat diese
Koalition am Wochenende gezeigt dass sie
gemeinsam handlungsfähig ist und mit 65
Milliarden Euro Großes bewegen kann und
das zählt am Ende in der Demokratie
und damit helfen wir vielen wir helfen
kleine mittleren Unternehmen wir helfen
Familie mit dem Kinderzuschlag und dem
Kindergeld wir helfen wir weiten das
Wohngeld aus wer entlasten Rennen und
Rentner Studierende Fachschülerinnen wir
führen bundesweit ein dauerhaftes
günstiges Ticket für den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr ein und es wird die größte
Erhöhung der ALG2 Regelsätze geben seit
Bestehen des Systems das kann sich sehen
lassen dieses Paket
und natürlich gibt es auch Punkte die
wir anders entschieden hätten ich nenne
jetzt CO2-Preis werden uns ein höheres
Bürgergeld vorstellen können auch das
Thema kalte Progression aber das
natürlich das Wesen von Kompromissen
dass man eine sich einigen muss und das
ein guter Kompromiss weil in die
richtige Richtung geht die Menschen die
mit kleinen mittleren Einkommen leiden
am stärksten unter der Fossil
getriebenen Inflation wenn man sie die
Zahlen anguckt entlassen will sie am
aller deutlichsten am meisten und
gleichzeitig haben wir
und gleichzeitig hat Kollege Rohde
darauf hingewiesen schöpfen wir
zufallsgewinne ab im Strommarkt von
Unternehmen die es nicht brauchen und
finanzieren Teil des Paket das ist
richtig und gerecht
und die schweren Krisen die wir zu
bewältigen haben sie eine
gesamtstaatliche Aufgabe der Bund ist
bereits ein Teil dafür zu tun und es um
klar noch mal zu sagen die Länder haben
zwischen mehr steuernamen als der Bund
2021 und 2022 plant im Gegensatz zum
Bund trotzdem mit extrem wenig
Notkrediten und ich finde die Länder die
jetzt egal welche Farbe übrigens
Unis ohne große entlassungspakete
gefordert haben die sondern auch ihren
fairen Beitrag zu Finanzierung dieser
entlastungspakete machen das ist nur
gerecht
und ich bin nochmal auf die Kritik der
Union eingehen zu den entlastungspaketen
warum brauchen wir überhaupt so hohe
entlassungspakete weil wir so eine hohe
Fossil getriebene Inflationen haben vor
allen Dingen bei Gas und vor allen
Dingen bei Öl und das ist der die
Wahrheit warum wir jetzt so eine massive
Krise haben wer hat denn 16 Jahre lang
regiert wer hat den Energiewende
blockiert wer hat denn Wind und Solar
sabotiert wo es eine gegenwärtige
Gebäude Sanierung verschlafen die
wärmewende nicht vorangetrieben wer hat
uns abhängig vom Putins Gras gemacht das
waren 16 Jahre Regierungspolitik der
Union sie haben uns ein angeblichen
Scherbenhaufen verlassen als Koalition
und wir ändern das jetzt im Rekordtempo
mit zehn Gesetzen zu erneuerbaren
Energien und Energiesicherheit hier vor
dem Sommer noch beschlossen haben und
dann bitte Berg ich empfehle ihn sich
ernsthaft mal den Stresstest genau
einfach mal durchzulesen wenn man sich
genau anguckt wir haben sie nicht
gemacht können sich angucken die 0, ich
erkläre in der Mittelberg 0,1% weniger
0,1 Prozent hätte einen Steckbrief von
AKW eine Effekt auf die Frage des
Gasverbrauchs also de facto gar nichts
führende Energie
Türen Energiemarkt Experten haben sehr
klar berechnet dass auch ist keine
signifikanten Effekte auf dem preisgebe
weil nämlich jetzt im jetzigen System
die höchsten Kraftwerke in höchsten
Preisen den Preis bestimmen in mehrere
order-effekt und nicht die
Atomkraftwerke und am letzten
der Stress das hat sehr klar geben dass
wir keine streckbetrieb brauchen und
keine Laufzeitverlängerung worum es
jetzt geht das im rekordtempus
unabhängig machen von Putins Graz zu
versuchen mit ihren atomdebatten davon
abzulegen welchen scherbenhaft in
unserer verlassen haben das werden wir
nicht durchgehen lassen
[Applaus]
im Gegenteil sie wollen es ja dass wir
weiter an mich hier sein Putins quasi
klagen ja gerade auch in Karlsruhe gegen
den transformations- und klimafond der
uns unabhängig macht bei
Energieeffizienz unabhängig macht den
wir Industrie anbauen indem wir
Klimaschutz vorantreiben gegen der ihre
Politik wurde dort dafür dass ihr weiter
abwechseln über Putins Öl und Gas und
das werden wir nicht zulassen
die letzten Wochen und Monat haben es
gezeigt wir müssen diesen
Haushaltsberatungen bei diesen schweren
Herbst und Winter der Form steht ein
Stück weit auch auf Sicht fahren weil
wir noch nicht alle Auswirkungen kennen
Kollege Roder darauf hingewiesen wir
wissen noch nicht wie sich die
corona-pandemie sehr schreckliche Krieg
auf unsere Gesellschaft auf die
Wirtschaft auf unsere öffentlichen
Haushalte auswirkt auch international
sehen wir dass wir noch deutlich
nachsteuerungsbedarf haben beim Thema
Welternährung beim Thema zivile
krisenbremse und humanitäre Hilfe wenn
ich mir den 23 angucke und die aktuellen
Zahlen sehen eher schwierig aus also das
Konsumklima geht runter der ifo
Geschäftsklimaindex ist auf dem nächsten
standsatz zwei Jahren und natürlich ist
klar auch in Situationen braucht man
eine aktive gestaltende Fiskalpolitik
darauf werden wir diesen Verhandlungen
auch im Parlament achten wir werden uns
in diesen Haushalt und in den nächsten
Haushalten als Koalition nicht in Krisen
hineinsparen wir werden das notwendig
das Richtige was wir brauchen auch
finanzieren und werden niemanden
Gesellschaft in dieser schweren Krise im
Stich lassen vielen Dank
Sven Christian Kindler für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen wo er
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher ist
haushaltspolitische
Sprecherin bzw stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzenden ist Gesine lötz
aus der Linksfraktion und wir sind immer
noch bei der allgemeinen finanzbindung
Debatte zum Haushalt 23 gut für Gas
Spekulanten Stromhändler Waffenhändler
Immobilienkonzern und Vermögende aber er
ist schlecht für Menschen die jeden Cent
umdrehen müssen sie werden mit einem
Mosen abgespeist das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren meine Damen und Herren
und dieser Haushalt ist schlecht für
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen deren
Existenz bedroht ist oder die schon
aufgeben mussten diese Unternehmen
brauchen wirksame Hilfen auch davon ist
in diesem Haushalt nicht zu finden das
muss ich ändern
die galoppierende Inflation treibt viele
Menschen in dramatische Probleme sie
wissen nicht mehr wie Sie Ihre Rechnung
bezahlen sollen aber die Bundesregierung
lässt sie im Regen stehen warum weil sie
nicht bereit ist die Krisengewinner
wirklich wirksam zu besteuern
stattdessen will sie mit einer gasumlage
Energiekonzerne entlasten obwohl viele
von ihnen in den Kriegsmonaten riesige
Gewinne erzielt haben Herr Habeck nennt
sie nun Trittbrettfahrer nein die
Wahrheit ist die Manager dieser Firmen
haben die gasumlage selbst
aufgeschrieben das ist 100% Lobbyismus
das nehmen wir nicht hin meine Damen und
Herren
wir fordern eine übergewinnsteuer die
bereits in vielen anderen Ländern
existiert wir könnten mit dieser Steuer
100 Milliarden Euro einnehmen damit
ließen sich Gasstrom und mietendeckeln
das wäre der richtige Weg meine Damen
und Herren
SPD und Grüne lassen sich von der FDP
unter Druck setzen und verweigern so
eine Steuer seien sie noch mutiger
gegenüber der FDP meine Damen und Herren
was hilft nun gegen die Preisexplosion
auf jeden Fall nicht die milden Gaben
die sie den Menschen am Wochenende
versprochen haben nein man muss an die
Ursachen der Explosion herangehen es
gibt zurzeit auf dieser Welt 20 Kriege
wir sprechen hier häufig über den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und wir
wissen alle dass eine Mehrheit der
Menschen in unserem Land fordert das
durch eine mutige entschlossene
internationale Friedensinitiative dieser
Krieg beendet werden muss das Leiden der
Menschen im Krieg in der Ukraine muss
beendet werden meine Damen und Herren
aber schauen wir in den Haushalt die
Rüstungsindustrie sitzt der Regierung im
Nacken im Einzelplan 14 also
Verteidigung oder Rüstung sind 50,1
Milliarden Euro für das Militär
vorgesehen doch in Wirklichkeit sind es
nach nato-kriterien berechnet 14
Milliarden Euro mehr also 64 Milliarden
Euro und wenn wir dieses Geld für Kitas
Schulen Universitäten Krankenhäuser
sozialen Wohnungsbau und Busse und
Bahnen ausgeben würden dann würden wir
unserer Land besser zukunftsfähiger und
sicherer machen meine Damen und Herren
wir haben das haben die anderen Kollegen
auch gesagt in den Haushaltsberatungen
viel zu tun der Haushalt muss sozial
werden er muss nachhaltig werden und er
muss zum Frieden in dieser Welt
beitragen vielen Dank
Gesine löt stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der Linksfraktion aber dort auch
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin und
Vorsitzende im Haushaltsausschuss ist
hier der auch schon mal gewesen der ist
schon ein bisschen länger her und du
Fricke ist am Pool der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
Putin auch nur einen Cent weniger
Gaspreise nehmen wird in dem Moment wo
es sogenannte Friedensverhandlungen gibt
das auf dem Rücken von Opfern in der
Ukraine so darzustellen ist eine
Verkennung der Realität es ist eine
Verkennung dessen wer Schuld an diesen
hohen Preisen ist und die diese
Koalition versucht hier abzufedern meine
Damen und Herren das ist der erste
Haushalt mit Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse nach zwei
ausnahmehaushalten wenn ich überlege wie
es noch hieß das werdet ihr niemals
schaffen einen Haushalt im Kabinett
vorzulegen das werdet ihr niemals
schaffen bis zum Ende der Sommerpause
das zu halten ihr werdet es ist niemals
schaffen wenn ihr ein drittes
Entlastungspaket macht noch einigermaßen
hier überhaupt eine solche
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten dann kann ich
nur sagen diese Koalition hat gezeigt
dass wenn man hart arbeitet wenn man
gegenseitig Kompromisse macht und dabei
immer an die Menschen denkt dann kann
man auch die Verfassung dann kann man
auch die Schuldenbremse einhalten und
darüber bin ich sehr froh meine Damen
und Herren
ich sage das auch deutlich ich bin ja
schon ganz froh dass ich im von Kollegen
Mittelberg nichts mehr von seinem
Fetisch nämlich von der schwarzen Null
gehört habe das war doch das was die CDU
immer wollte ist interessant dass sie
das jetzt nicht mehr sagen und zweiter
Punkt in Richtung cduell merkt sie sagen
oh das wäre ein Trick mit der Rücklage
wenn sie wirklich der Meinung sind dass
wir in Not Zeiten Rücklagen die für
notseiten sind nicht nehmen sollen dann
bin ich auf die Haushaltsberatung mit
ihrer Fraktion im Haushaltsausschuss
gespannt wo sie diese 40 Milliarden
einsparen werden und das als zweites in
ihre Richtung wir stehen hier und hören
von ihnen auch gleich von anderen
Rednern der CDU und der einst mal zu
stolzen CSU ja da muss man mehr sparen
da muss man vernünftiger sein und wenn
sie dann alle Sex sind kommen die
Fachpolitiker und sagt ach was
interessiert mich das Geschwätz meiner
Vorgänger vorhin da macht ihr zu wenig
da müsst ihr mehr machen da müsst ihr
was machen da lobe ich mir schon die
Ehrlichkeit der Linken an der Stelle und
ich kann Ihnen das auch sagen wissen Sie
ich bleib da beim Sommer nachts Traum
und ich glaube bei ihnen ist da auch so
ein bisschen Sommernachtstraum noch
hängen geblieben es ist nicht genug dass
man Rede man muss auch richtig reden und
da ist ihre Aufgabe als Opposition uns
wirklich Vorschläge zu machen und nicht
einfach nur zu sagen ich hätte es gerne
anders aber ich weiß eigentlich nicht
wie ich sehe bei der Rente Probleme ich
weiß aber nicht wie ich sehe an ganz
vielen Stellen bei der Energieprobleme
ich weiß aber nicht wie es löse machen
Sie doch mal einen alternativen
durchgerechnet in echten anderen
Lösungsvorschlag dann gehen wir auch
gerne mit ihnen allen in die Debatte
meine Damen und Herren
es ist
es ist dann auch noch mal angesprochen
worden und das sage ich auch weil die
Bank natürlich wieder leer ist ich meine
ich bin auch nicht da darüber erfreut
dass nachdem der Kollege Tonka hier
einbringt nach einer nach dem anderen
die Minister verschwinden und die
sicherlich leistungsfähigen
parlamentarischen Staatssekretär hier
sitzen aber was auf der bundesratsbank
passiert ist wieder typisch wir erleben
das und ich sage das für alle egal wer
jetzt in der Regierung oder jetzt in der
Opposition ist das ist ja das Schöne
Demokratie dass das mal wechselt wenn es
so weitergehen wird dass die Länder
immer wieder sagen ich bin zwar
zuständig die Verfassung hat mir auch
die Erträge dafür gegeben aber es soll
gefälligst der Bund alles zahlen dann
wird dieser Bundeshaushalt nicht
befähigt sein und ich hätte erwartet
dass von ihnen dazu in Erinnerung an den
Kollegen Rehberg den wir alle an der
Stelle immer unterstützt haben egal ob
in Opposition der Regierung werden etwas
mehr gekommen wäre dass wir hier auch
stehen denn die Verhandlungen die da
gebe ich dem Kollegen
vollkommen Recht wenn Christian Kindler
die Verhandlungen werden ja nicht nur
hier geführt sie werden ja auch noch mit
dem Ministerpräsidenten geführt das wird
eine Haushaltsberatung werden ich bin
gespannt was an Vorschlägen kommt ich
fürchte von dieser Bank werden keine
guten Vorschläge kommen versuchen Sie es
ein wenig die Hoffnung ist da die
Regierung hat Ihre Vorlagen gemacht das
Parlament wird seine Arbeit tun und ich
bin mir sicher dass wenn wir im November
über den Haushalt reden werden alle
erkennen es ist der Haushalt einer
stabilen sozialen Marktwirtschaft aber
es gibt keine Weihnachtsgeschenke denn
Ende November steht es im Gesetz
herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion und zum Thema
Bund Länder und Finanzen vom Bund an die
Länder hat der Bundesrechnungshof in
seinem Bericht zu diesem Haushalt auch
ein paar Anmerkungen gemacht unter
anderem hat er den Bund vorgehalten dass
durch die Steuerverteilung dem Bund von
22 bis 26 rund 100 Milliarden Euro durch
verzichte zugunsten der Länder entgehen
zusätzlich so heißt es finanziere der
Bund länderausgaben mit zweifelhafter
Wirksamkeit das am Rande Sebastian Brehm
ist derweil ans Pult getreten Sprecher
für Haushalt und Finanzen der
CSU-Landesgruppe
Verschuldung ist mit rund 78 Milliarden
Euro vierfach höher als im
bundeshaushaltsplan ausgewiesen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der sagt nicht
ich sondern er sagt der
Bundesrechnungshof und hat es ihnen in
die Bücher geschrieben von liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
und wenn der Bundesrechnungshof sowas
sagt dann treibt ihn die tiefe Sorge um
die Zukunft Deutschlands und diese tiefe
Sorge teile ich liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der Haushalt ist eine reine Mogelpackung
der Finanzminister verkündet 17,2
Milliarden Neuverschuldung Sie entnehmen
40,5 Milliarden aus der asylrücklage und
greifen noch auf die geschummelten 60
Milliarden aus dem Nachtragshaushalt
2021 zu wir klagen dagegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
intransparente und unseriöse
Haushaltspolitik liebe Kollegen auch bei
den Investitionen verkünden sie einen
Rekordwert aber rechnet man es mal
sauber raus also die Zuzahlungen die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung die
Zahlung in den klimafon des IWF dann
haben wir die niedrigsten Investitionen
und wer hätte gedacht dass die Grünen
sogar eine Verringerung der
Investitionen in die Schiene vornehmen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und darüber hinaus fehlt in dem Haushalt
gänzlich das was sie am Wochenende
beschlossen haben 65 Milliarden Euro sie
haben 10 Milliarden Euro pauschal
eingeplant was machen Sie mit den
restlichen 55 Milliarden wer soll das
bezahlen Bund Länder Kommunen kein Wort
im laufenden Haushalt sie legen einen
Haushalt vor der von Anfang an nicht
stimmt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und fangen sie nicht an
uns die ganze Situation in die Schuhe zu
schieben die SPD war übrigens den
letzten Jahren auch in der Regierung ich
weiß dass Vergesslichkeit gerade bei der
SPD und beim Bundeskanzler gerade im
Moment Mainstream sind aber wir haben 16
Jahre lang bewiesen dass
Wirtschaftspolitik Wachstum
Beschäftigung und solide Finanzen
zusammengehören wir haben die
Wirtschaftskrise
2008/2009 gemeistert wir haben die
corona-krise gemeistert und wir haben
insgesamt die Staatsverschuldung gesenkt
wir haben insgesamt Wirtschaftswachstum
gehab einen gesunden und stabilen
Mittelstand und wir hatten die höchsten
Beschäftigungszahlen in Deutschland und
sie machen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jetzt die Menschen in unserem
Land Erna und den Mittelstand liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen machen sie gänzlich
kaputt und Liebe Kollege Rohde das muss
ich schon mal sagen wenn Sie ein
Mittelberg gleich in die rechte Ecke
stellen wenn er Kritik äußert
das ist Tiere rot-grüne
mainstream-politik wenn ihnen die
Meinung nicht passt dann wird man sofort
in die rechte Ecke gestellt sie
interessiert doch gar nicht die Kritik
der Opposition sie haben ein
Demokratieverständnis was völlig falsch
am Platz ist und die Regierung ist ja
gar nicht anwesend wenn die Opposition
spricht das ist eigentlich skandalös
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich mache mir große Sorgen um den
deutschen Mittelstand anstatt die
Angebotsseite auch bei der Energie zu
erweitern und in den Blick zu nehmen
verringern sie bewusst Kapazitäten aus
rein ideologischer Überzeugung Stichwort
Kernkraftwerke und der Kindler
wenn sie sagen dass die Verlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke nicht in Ordnung ist dann
haben sie die Lage aktuell nicht
begriffen was sie da tun ist
unverantwortlich sie hören ja nicht
immer mehr zu was sie da tun ist und
verantwortlich was sie machen ist auf
Kohle zu setzen auf fracking-gas ein
schwertankern die nach Deutschland
kommen das ist die neue grüne
Klimapolitik in Deutschland liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was sagen sie
den Bäcker an dem Metzger was sagen Sie
dem Landwirt der nicht mehr in
Deutschland produzieren kann was sagen
sie der Lackiererei dem Metallbetrieb
den Chemiebetrieb der Glashütte der
Brauerei sie sagen gar nichts denn es
kommt kein einziger Vorschlag zur
Stützung des Mittelstandes zu Entlastung
des Mittelstandes das einzige was sie
sagen und das ist ja ehrlich gesagt ein
Hohn sie von der FDP machen leider bei
diesen ganzen Spielchen mit das ist
wirklich größt enttäuschend was sie hier
in der Bundesregierung abliefern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der FDP sie
sagen los man soll KfW-Kredite aufnehmen
diese KfW-Kredite können die
Mittelständler überhaupt nicht mehr
zurückzahlen in der jetzigen Lage und
ein Großteil der Erwerbstätigen muss
zusehen wie sie maroden gaskonzernen
Geld ohne jegliche Bedingungen
zuschanzen zahlen darf es der arbeitende
Bürger der Mittelständler mit der
gasumlage schaffen Sie diese gasumlage
ab sie ist unsozial und ungerecht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und die FDP wenn ihr dann ein Jahr wir
machen ja eine Entlastung der Bürger mit
der kalten Progression erstens erst ab
dem Jahr 2023 skandalöses müsste im Jahr
2022 schon stattfinden und zweitens ist
die kalte Progression die Entlastung der
kalten Progression keine Entlastung
sondern sie ist eine Abminderung der
Belastung die sie den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern zumuten wir haben es ja schon
gesagt die Steuereinnahmen sind 16,2%
höher in diesem Jahr also könnten Sie
jederzeit Entlastungen vornehmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für uns ist die
Abschaffung der kalten Progression immer
eine Selbstverständlichkeit gewesen die
wir alle zwei Jahre wie vereinbart
durchgeführt haben liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen entweder sie können die Krise
nicht
oder Sie wollen es bewusst so und beides
ist verheerend für den Standort
Deutschland wenn ein Betrieb erst mal zu
macht
und sich verlagert
dann macht er nicht mehr auf und das
Land verändert sich kolossal der
deutsche Mittelstand ist unser Stolz und
ist die Stärke in unsere Wirtschaft wenn
Sie diesen kaputt machen und das machen
sie gerade dann legen Sie Axt an die
Gesellschaft in Deutschland und an
unsere miteinander in unserem Land
was wir brauchen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir brauchen Einsparungen im
Haushalt sie sagen sie sparen Personal
ein dann kürzen Sie auch die stellen sie
haben 10.000 neue Stellen geschaffen in
der neuen Regierung also erzählen Sie
doch nichts vom Personalkürzungen ziehen
Sie es wenn dann durch 4.000 stellen
könnten Sie mit diesen 1,5% einziehen
das tun sie mit diesem Haushalt nicht
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
einer
20-stunden-work live-balance Einstellung
werden wir die Volkswirtschaft nicht
schaffen sondern wir müssen
Arbeitsanreize setzen ich komme auch zum
Schluss wir müssen arbeitsanreise setzen
Respekt aber nicht wenn wir kürzen zum
Beispiel wenn die Rentnerinnen und
Renten wenn die Rentner Arbeiten kürzen
wir dann die Witwenrente
oder wenn Sie die Sanktionen gegen
Arbeitslose abschaffen so schaffen wir
nicht Arbeit und nur mit Arbeit und
Wachstum kommen wir aus der Krise wir
bieten an ihnen zu helfen wir bieten an
in Versprechen zu gehen aber das muss
auf augenhöhlich seinen Kollegen
herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Brehm aus der CSU Landesgruppe
der ist der Sprecher für Haushalt und
Finanzen hat förmlich oder quasi wie im
Übergang eingeleitet für die letzte
Runde in dieser allgemeinen
finanzdebatte da werden die
Finanzpolitiker noch ein bisschen ein
Übergewicht haben und da ist der nächste
Redner jetzt
Andreas
bitte um Entschuldigung
finanzpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion
die Wirtschaft unsere Gesellschaft in
den letzten Jahrzehnten durchmachen muss
Putin führten Krieg gegen die Ukraine
nicht nur bei diesen angriffskriegs
sondern auch einen Krieg er führt an den
Krieg mit anderen Waffen mit der Energie
als Waffe Nahrungsmittel als Waffe er
will Staaten destabilisieren unsere
Gesellschaft die stabilisieren wir
Situation
halten
Rednerinnen Redner der größten
Oppositionspartei
hier reden in denen sie
teilweise unsachlich kritisieren keine
eigenen vorschlage
liefern wie dieser Situation halten
cduceu Politiker reden die in der
schreckender Weise deutlich machen dass
sich diese immer staatstragende
Kanzlerpartei zu einer populistischen
Oppositionspartei entwickelt das ist an
dieser Situation
vollkommen unangemessen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und die
Bundesregierung haben immer wieder klar
gemacht dass in dieser Situation
wie die Menschen die alleine lassen
werden
dass wir einen starken Staat einen
starken Sozialstaat haben mit dem wir
auch in der Zukunft sozialen
Zusammenhalt
organisieren die Ampelkoalition hat mit
dem Entlastungspaket schon Wochenende
habe diesen Haushalt habe in den 100
Milliarden das entlassungspaketes zu den
30 Milliarden nochmal 65 dem
vorliegenden Haushalt ganz genau die
richtige Antwort gegeben wir stehen als
Deutschland zusammen wir werden alles
Möglichkeiten gute diese Krise zu kommen
und das ist das Signal das von diesem
Haushalt und diesen entlastungspaketen
ausgeht meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
dazu gibt es weil es keine klassische
Inflation ist sondern eine Preisschock
sind auch nicht die klassischen und
einfachen Lösungen für diese
Probleme deswegen gibt es verschiedene
Maßnahmen der Staatssekretär Tonka hat
es auch deutlich gemacht wir werden auf
der einen Seite dafür sorgen dass wir
Energiepreise dämpfen dass wir damit
auch die Inflation dämpfen wir werden in
den Markt eingreifen wir werden eine
strompreisbremse einbauen und werden vor
allen Dingen dafür sorgen dass
leistungslose das krisenbedingte
übergewinne wie abschöpfen werden und
den Menschen zurückgeben es ist auch
eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit und der
Stabilität das Unternehmen mit ihren
zufallsgewinn zu Bekämpfung der Krise
beitragen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir werden das auf den Weg
bringen und wir werden gleichzeitig auch
ein weitere Frage der Gerechtigkeit
nämlich die globale Mindeststeuer hier
auch national auf den Weg bringen die
Milliarden Einnahmen auch für den Staat
bedeuten die wir wieder in den
Krisenbekämpfung geben können auch das
wird jetzt auf den Weg gebracht meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
zweitens wir müssen täglich aus
Erfahrung im Wahlkreis aber auch aus
Studien
feststellen dass natürlich gerade
diejenigen mit kleinen mit mittleren
Einkommen von den hohen Teuerungsraten
am stärksten betroffen sind und deswegen
haben wir uns auch darauf geeinigt
weiter mit Direktzahlungen die Probleme
der Menschen abzufedern jetzt im
September
werden für 44 Millionen Menschen
die energiepreispauschale 300 Euro
ausgezahlt wir werden genau diese
Direktzahlungen jetzt auch in den
nächsten Wochen Monaten für die Rentner
Rente für Studierende auf den Weg
bringen wir werden natürlich auch dafür
sorgen dass Löhne angemessen steigen
müssen dafür sind diese zahlpartner
zuständig aber wenn die sich auch darauf
einigen dass es zusätzlich arbeitgeber
und Gewerkschaften das ist zusätzliche
Zahlungen geben soll die in dieser Krise
helfen können die Menschen helfen können
dann werden wir dafür sorgen dass wir
bis zu 3000 Euro hier Freistellen von
Steuern und Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
auch das ein wichtiger Beitrag zur
Krisenbekämpfung meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
und auch für die Unternehmen ist
übrigens
gesorgt und daran gedacht worden wir
werden
energieintensive Unternehmen
weiterhin in sogenannten
Spitzenausgleich gewähren das sind 1,7
Milliarden Euro an Entlastungen für
Unternehmen und die umsatzsteuersenko in
der Gastronomie werden wir auch
verlängern auch das deutliche Signale
hinein in die Betriebe in die
Unternehmen dass wir hier an ihrer Seite
stehen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir werden diese Beiträge in
diesen Haushalt mit dieser
lassungspaketen Einbringen der
Oppositionsführer hat gesagt er möchte
die Zusammenarbeit anbieten aber da
stellt sich doch mal die Frage welches
Angebot gilt denn da
Herr Merz beklagt die Angebotslücke bei
der Energieversorgung ist der gleiche
März der im März das Gas im Bahnhof
vorgeschlagen hätte die Preise in die
Höhe getrieben hätte die energielücken
noch größer gemacht hätte was gilt denn
nun meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
von der cdu/csu an der Stelle ein kommen
Sie bitte zum Schluss es ist dasselbe
Herr Merz der mehr
Unterstützungsleistungen will aber wenn
es so geht gegen den Mindestlohn
agitiert hat gegen die Stabilisierung
des rindenniveaus agitiert hat was gilt
denn nun meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren von der cdu/csu schon in letzter
Satz bitte wenn wir die
unfallgeschwindigkeit und die
Drehgeschwindigkeit von Herrn Nerz
Energie umwandeln könnten keine
Energiekrise so müssen wir aber dafür
sorgen und werden das tun für
Energiesicherheit zu sorgen dieses
kleinen Krise zu bringen und da machen
wir das andere Kollektion geschlossen an
die Arbeit
Michael schrodi muss jetzt mal zweimal
ermahnt werden von Yvonne Marc was der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin die das
ansonsten hier doch relativ locker
laufen lässt was die Redezeiten angeht
und was die Redezeiten angeht ist jetzt
Andreas autrett dran für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen da ist er
stellvertretender Vorsitzender
das werde ich genauso tun frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir gehen auf dem sehr
schwierigen Winter zu das wissen wir
alle und das was jetzt im Mittelpunkt
stehen muss ist dass wir solidarisch
sind und dass wir alle Menschen gut
durch diese Zeit bringen und das dritte
Entlastungspaket was am Wochenende
verhandelt wurde ist ein wichtiger
Schritt auf genau diesem Weg
unsere grüne Logik bei den Verhandlungen
zu diesem Entlastungspaket war die Hilfe
muss bei denen ankommen die es am
härtesten getroffen hat und die es am
härtesten trifft und ich sage ganz offen
nicht jede Maßnahme in diesem
Entlastungspaket erfüllt diesen Anspruch
ich hätte anders agiert an vielen
Stellen ich hätte nicht Menschen die
200.000 die 300.000 Euro verdienen auch
noch Geld dazu gegeben das ist nicht die
Logik das ist beileibe nicht das wofür
wir Grüne gekämpft haben wir hatten die
Menschen mit wenig Geld im Blick wir
hatten die Menschen mit kleinen
Einkommen mit mittleren Einkommen im
Blick und wir haben für die jede Menge
rausgeholt
50 Euro ich bin mal ein paar Punkte
nennen 50 Euro mehr für Menschen in der
Grundsicherung das ist die höchste
Anhebung jemals in im Regelsatz und vor
allem wir werden in die
Berechnungsmethode hineingehen und die
ändern wir werden sie im Kern verändern
künftig Inflation auch in der Zukunft
mit einbeziehen und damit auch dauerhaft
die Regelsätze nach oben schieben das
Kindergeld steigt um 18 Euro der
Kinderzuschlag um 21 Euro die Grundlage
für eine Kindergrundsicherung die wir
auf den Weg bringen werden alle im
Wohngeld bekommen noch mal 415 Euro
Heizkostenzuschuss und dann reformieren
wir das Wohngeld für Studierende für
Rentnerinnen gibt es 200 300 Euro
strompreisbremse kommt für den
basisverbrauch und wir werden Strom und
Gas sperren unterbinden das werden wir
tun eine warme Wohnung im Winter Strom
für den Alltag das wird für alle
garantiert sein und dafür sorgen wir ich
habe gesagt nicht jede Maßnahme diese
dieses Paketes ist meine aber es gibt
einen wichtigen Punkt die
Gesamtverteilung verteilungswirkung geht
jetzt vor allem nach Juden und in die
Mitte und das war die Voraussetzung für
uns zuzustimmen das haben wir heraus
verhandelt das ist jetzt im Paket und
deswegen ist es ein gutes Paket
wir müssen die aktuelle Krise bewältigen
und gleichzeitig dürfen wir nicht die
Zukunft vergessen deswegen muss klar
sein jeder Sektor muss einen Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz leisten und das gilt auch
für den Verkehrssektor wir haben auch an
der Stelle jede Menge rausgeholt am
Wochenende das 9 euro-ticket wird eine
Nachfolge bekommen das haben wir
geschafft und zweitens da haben sie Herr
Brem öffentlich sichtlich am Wochenende
in Nickerchen gemacht das sei ihnen
gegönnt aber bislang war die
Finanzierung der Schiene zu tief dass es
richtig Wärme verhandelt jetzt haben wir
1,5 Milliarden Euro noch mal draufgelegt
so macht man Politik so macht man
Klimaschutz und genau das haben wir am
Wochenende auf den Weg gebracht
ein weiterer Punkt ist mir wichtig der
Diktator Putin der greift uns hier mit
Gaspreisen und Propaganda an der
Diktator Putin greift in anderen Teilen
der Welt mit Hungerkrisen an Annalena
baerbock hat eine Außenpolitik neu
definiert die dieser harten
Auseinandersetzung gerecht wird und
darum ist es so wichtig dass wir dann
wenn es darauf ankommt nicht am Geld
sparen auch das ist eine Sache die wir
uns ganz genau angeschaut haben und
deswegen ist es so wichtig um diese
Antwort geben zu können dass wir noch
mal eine Milliarde Euro für
Ernährungssicherung draufpacken die
Botschaft ist klar wir kümmern uns um
die Ärmsten und wir geben dem Diktator
Putin keinen Raum das gilt für
Deutschland und das geht gleichermaßen
weltweit
der Winter der hat noch nicht begonnen
und wir sehen jetzt schon dass die
Herausforderungen riesig werden und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir jetzt
übergewinne im Strommarkt abschöpfen um
zu sagen wir brauchen dieses Geld und
das heißt auch für die Zukunft für die
nächsten Monate wir können uns aus
dieser Krise nicht heraussparen und wir
werden unsere Politik auch in den
kommenden Monaten nicht an Dogmen aus
Wahlprogrammen festmachen sondern an der
Realität das ist der Grundsatz die Ampel
wird Verantwortung übernehmen genau das
machen wir zusammen und deswegen ist es
ein guter Weg den wir gemeinsam
beschreiten können dankeschön
[Applaus]
stellvertretendervorsitzender der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Bundestag und damit ist er der
drittletzte Redner in dieser allgemeinen
finanzdebatte gewesen in zu deren
beginnt der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Tonka den Bundeshaushalt
zu 23 hier eingebracht hat jetzt
Christoph Meyer FDP auch erst
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
politischen Normalität da wir haben die
Zahlen bereits gehört 445 Milliarden
Euro über 50 Milliarden Euro
Investitionssumme dass es mehr als im
letzten
undionssentwurf
beinhaltet war für das Jahr 2023 und wir
sind trotz der Krisen ausgewogen
unterwegs trotz der des Zustandes des
Landes ausgewogen unterwegs auf der
einen Seite investieren wir auf der
einen Seite treffen wir Vorsorge für die
Krise und auf der anderen Seite halten
wir die Neuverschuldung schwierig auf
17,2 Milliarden Euro damit halten wir
die Schuldenbremse ein und das ist ein
gutes Zeichen nach drei Jahren
Ausnahmezustand
und wir werden das und wir werden das
auch für die Jahre 2024 25 sicherstellen
am Ende des Tages werden wir dafür Sorge
tragen dass wir jetzt die Grundlagen
schaffen dieses Land vorzubereiten auf
die nächsten Krisen und da muss ihnen
ganz ehrlich sagen Herr Mittelberg und
Herr Bremen ich kann das aus ihrer
Perspektive verstehen wenn sie nach der
Argumentation was interessiert uns
unsere Zeit in der unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung was interessiert uns an
Verantwortung was wir damals an
Versäumnissen haben das ist alles schön
und gut aber ihr Gedächtnis geht noch
nicht mal bis zu den Haushaltsberatungen
2022 zurück da waren sie es da war es
die Union die die asylrücklage in Höhe
von 48 Milliarden Euro auflösen wollte
sie waren es die uns genau hier jetzt
das vorwerfen was sie damals wollten und
da muss ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen so
billig kommen Sie hier nicht davon
und das gilt für alle anderen Vorwürfe
die sie hier gemacht haben auch das ist
der Bereich stellenaufwuchs das sind vor
allen Stellen im Bereich Zoll im Bereich
Bundespolizei sind sie denn dagegen dass
der Zoll besser ausgestattet wird oder
die Bundespolizei das müssten Sie doch
mal sagen das ist doch der eigentliche
Skandal den Sie hier uns mitteilen
wollen
so was interessiert mich mein Geschwätz
von gestern das scheint offensichtlich
die Devise sein mit der die Union
mittlerweile Haushaltspolitik macht das
ist schade und das gilt auch zum
Beispiel für den ganzen Bereich Zinsen
sie haben immer noch nicht verstanden wo
der Unterschied liegt zwischen Zinsen
und Zinskosten das ist nämlich das
Problem was wir haben dass wir von der
Vorgängerregierung von der
unionsgeführten Regierung hier ob das
das Thema Inflationsausgleich ist oder
des Agio ist wir hier kosten Erben die
wir jetzt ausgeben müssen als
Zusatzkosten zu dem steigenden Zins als
solches und deswegen ist ihre gesamte
Argumentation hier leider nicht sehr
viel wert wir halten die Schuldenbremse
ein wir entlasten die Mitte mit der
einem Abbau der kalten Progression das
haben sie uns alles nicht zugetraut ich
gehe davon aus dass wir bis November
intensive Haushaltsberatungen haben aber
am Ende des Tages werden wir ein genauso
guten Haushalt verabschieden wir jetzt
im Entwurf vorliegt ich danke Ihnen für
die Aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf
die Beratung
Christoph Meyer kurz und bündig für die
FDP-Fraktion das liegt auch daran das
habe ich Ihnen vorhin vorenthalten dass
sie von Mark was die Redezeiten jetzt
hier am Ende noch mal ein bisschen
gekürzt hat was im Vorfeld nicht so
wirklich aus dem Ruder gelaufen war aber
doch ein bisschen undiszipliniert
vonstatten gegangen ist deswegen muss
hier jetzt eingespart werden am Ende
auch bei Frauke Heiligenstadt aus der
SPD-Fraktion
allerlei Kritik geübt am vorliegenden
Haushaltsplan Entwurf versucht kein
einziges gutes Haar an den Vorschlägen
der Bundesregierung für die Entlastung
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu lassen
daher liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
CDU müssen sie sich auch gefallen lassen
dass wir uns Ihre Vorschläge eben mal
angeschaut haben deshalb habe ich mir
mal ihr Papier von Anfang September mit
der Überschrift Klarheit in unsicheren
Zeiten vorgenommen und nachgeschaut was
sie denn so anders machen würden so
fordern Sie zum Beispiel die Abschaffung
der gasumlage Sie erklären den Menschen
allerdings nicht mit welchen Mitteln aus
dem Haushalt sie die Insolvenzen bei den
Versorgungsunternehmen abwenden und
damit auch die Gasversorgung
sicherstellen wollen Klarheit in unsere
Firmen Zeiten fehlanzeige
oder
nehmen wir einmal den Punkt zur
Atomkraft sie fordern die deutliche
Weiternutzung der Atomenergie sogar
einschließlich des Erwerbs von neuen
kernbrennstäben dem ganzen Thema widmen
sie in ihrem Papier übrigens sag und
schreibe elf Zeilen und konkreter
Formulierungen sie berücksichtigen dabei
aber die weder die Kosten eines
Weiterbetriebs von Atomkraftwerken
genauso wenig also wie den Erwerb von
kernbrennstäben oder mögliche
Schadenersatzforderungen der
Atomindustrie die die Kosten des
Ausstiegs aus dem Ausstieg vom Ausstieg
sicherlich thematisieren werden Klarheit
in unsicheren Zeiten fehlanzeige
ein weiteres Beispiel ist ihre
Abwrackprämie für Energiefresser sie
sind so unkreativ dass sie alte Ideen
aus dem letzten Jahrzehnt die damals
auch schwierig funktioniert haben
einfach recyceln sie fordern also jetzt
die Abwrackprämie für Kühlschränke mal
abgesehen davon dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger momentan häufig gar kein Geld für
neue Geräte haben könnten sie mit den
von Ihnen vorgeschlagenen drei Millionen
Geräten vielleicht gerade noch mal
Berlin die Haushalte in Berlin
ausstatten aber für den Rest der
Republik bräuchten sie deutlich mehr
Geld Finanzierung Klarheit in unsicheren
Zeiten
Fehlanzeige meine Damen und Herren
ich könnte aus ihrem Papier noch ein
paar weitere Punkte nennen die entweder
sehr unkonkret sind und keinerlei
finanzierungshinweise beinhalten ich
belasse es jetzt aber mal bei diesen
drei Beispielen bei der
Gesamtfinanzierung des Haushaltes
fordern sie ohnehin immer nur mehr mehr
mehr wenn es um die fachpolitik geht
während ihre Finanzpolitiker und
finanzpolitikerinnen und
Haushaltspolitiker immer sagen
Schuldenbremse einhalten und keine
Steuern erhöhen oder keine Abgaben
erhöhen beides zusammen funktioniert
aber auch nicht kurzum sie können hier
Vorschläge machen so viel Sie wollen
vielleicht ist das was für Sommerloch
wenn sie aber wieder ernst genommen
werden wollen mit ihren Vorschlägen dann
müssen sie schon
regierungsfähige Vorschläge machen
ansonsten bleibt mir nichts anderes zu
sagen man braucht die Union in der
Opposition weniger als jetzt
Frauke Heiligenstadt aus der
SPD-Fraktion war die letzte Rednerin in
der allgemeinen finanzdebatte die
traditionell die haushaltswoche eröffnet
nachdem der Haushalt eingebracht worden
war von Florian Tonka dem
parlamentarischen Staatssekretär beim
Bundesfinanzminister in Vertretung von
Christian Lindner der wegen eines
Trauerfalls heute hier nicht sein konnte
und jetzt geht es hier weiter mit den
einzeletats der einzelnen Ministerien
auch das Kanzleramts und weitere
etaposten werden in den nächsten Tagen
besprochen und auf der Agenda hier und
heute steht jetzt der Einzelplan 17 das
ist der Etat des Ministeriums für
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend und
das wiederum bedeutet das Lisa Paus die
zuständige Ministerin und die
verantwortliche Ministerin für dieses
Ressort seit Ende April hier gleich zu
ihrem Etat Stellung nehmen wird
viereinhalb Monate knapp ist dieser Paus
ja jetzt Ministerin in der Nachfolge von
Anne Spiegel der Etat
Familienministeriums soll umfassen nach
jetzigem Stand nach entwurfsstand des
Haushalts 12,9 Milliarden Euro das sind
280 Millionen mehr als in diesem Jahr
und dann ist die Ministerin auch schon
am Pult und wird über Schwerpunkte ihres
Ministeriums berichten
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen sehr
geehrte Gäste sehr geehrte zuschauende
jeder und jeden von ihnen fällt sofort
ein Beispiel ein wie die aktuellen
Krisen Ihren persönlichen Alltag
finanziell belasten wie teuer Kartoffeln
Brot Strom Energie und erst recht Urlaub
geworden sind
wir sehen das wir tun was dagegen wir
lassen niemanden in schwierigen Zeiten
allein meine Damen und Herren
wohl dem der nicht jeden Cent der nicht
auf jeden Cent achten muss oder eine
eigene Vorstellung davon hat mit den
steigenden Kosten umzugehen das
Bundesministerium für Familie Senioren
Familien und Jugend hat aber die im
Blick die das nicht können die Eltern
die Alleinerziehenden die schon vor
Corona eisern geh haushaltet und alles
für ihre Kinder getan haben damit sie
ihnen Buntstifte ordentliche Schuhe ein
gesundes Essen bieten können die
Senioren die weiterhin selbstbestimmt
leben und am gesellschaftlichen Leben
teilhaben wollen die Jugendlichen die in
der corona-krise auch so vieles
verzichtet haben die aber eine gute
Zukunft verdienen und so wichtig sind
für unsere Gesellschaft und für eine
nachhaltige Transformation unseres
Handelns und unseres Wirtschaftens
die Frauen die in allen Krisen den Laden
zusammen und am Laufen halten in der
Gesellschaft in den Familien und immer
wieder schlechter bezahlt sind als
Männer oder eben auch gar nicht bezahlt
werden für ihre kehrarbeit für Kinder
und für ihre Angehörigen
dieser Fokus prägt den Haushalt 23
meines Ministeriums wir entlasten in der
Krise und wir investieren in die Zukunft
meine Damen und Herren
der Haushaltsentwurf ein metat von rund
12,9 Milliarden Euro vor die wir für
Familien und gesellschaftlich
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
einsetzen werden für mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit also
an erster Stelle steht Kinderarmut zu
bekämpfen darum die Kinder
Grundsicherung sie wird
einkommensschwachen Familie
sie wird einkommensschwache Familien
unterstützen weil es neben dem
garantiebetrag ein einkommensabhängigen
Zusatzbetrag geben wird und wir werden
Sie so einfach ausgestalten dass sie
wirklich alle Kinder erreicht auch
unabhängig vom Familienmodell ihrer
Eltern
so lindern wir Kinderarmut so kommen wir
sozialer Chancengerechtigkeit endlich
ein großes Stück näher bis das 2025
soweit ist werden die Kinder die mit
Hartz IV auskommen müssen oder Wohngeld
bekommen einen sofortzuschlag bekommen
von 20 Euro pro Monat das sind für 2023
insgesamt rund 1,5 Milliarden Euro mit
dem Entlastungspaket gehen wir aber noch
einen Schritt weiter und erhöhen das
Kindergeld um 18 Euro pro Monat das
entlastet familiengezielt von den Kosten
der Inflation denn sie trifft die
Inflation ganz besonders
und wir erhöhen auch für Kinder im Hartz
iv-bezug mit dem Bürgergeld die
Regelsätze damit die Ärmsten oder den
Kindern besser geschützt sind Vorabend
und das sind alles weitere wichtige
Schritte hinzu Kindergrundsicherung
lieber Abgeordnete Liebe zuschauende
Kinder lernen früh sie lernen schnell
und sie lernen gründlich und am besten
fördern wir Sie durch eine gute
frühkindliche Bildung in den Kitas und
zwar überall in Deutschland
und deshalb das Gute
kita-qualitätsgesetz und bevor hier
irgendjemand behauptet wir schaffen die
sprachkitas abräume ich mit dem Irrtum
auf wir nehmen in den nächsten zwei
Jahren viel Milliarden Euro in die Hand
und investieren ganz gezielt in die
Qualität der Kindertagesbetreuung und
das heißt konkret in qualifiziertes
Fachpersonal in gute Ausstattung in
Gesundheit Ernährung und Bewegung und
das heißt vorrangig in die sprachliche
Bildung
und die Länder haben es nun in der Hand
die Förderung der sprachlichen Bildung
mit Hilfe der Bundesmittel zur
verstetigen wir brauchen eben die
Regelfinanzierung der Sprachförderung
und nicht weiter irgendwelche
Modellprojekte wir legen das Geld zu wir
stellen das Geld zur Verfügung aber tun
müssen ist jetzt die Länder mit uns
gemeinsam meine Damen und Herren
und das ist auch ganz wichtig weil wir
brauchen in Deutschland gemeinsame und
Breite Qualitätsstandards in den Kitas
und auch daran werden wir weiter
arbeiten damit Kinder hochqualifiziert
betreut werden egal wo sie leben auch
das ist unsere Investition in die
Zukunft
ich war vor zwei Wochen in
Sachsen-Anhalt in Teutschenthal wo
Jugendliche mit Mitteln des
corona-auf-pakets von Mai bis August ein
selbst geplantes Sport- und
Freizeitgelände ein Jugendtreff und
einen digitalen Infokanal aus dem Boden
gestampft haben und das in vier Monaten
das geht meine Damen und Herren
die sind jetzt stolz wie Wolle
und das weil es ihr Projekt ist sie
haben es geplant sie haben es
durchgeführt und sie werden erst jetzt
fliegen und das macht sie stark meine
Damen und Herren genau da werden wir mit
dem zukunftspaket für Bewegung Kultur
und Gesundheit einsetzen 50 Millionen
Euro für Projekte von Jugendlichen und
Kindern zum Ausgleich und zum Nachholen
nach dem ganzen Verzicht der
corona-monate
das passt zu unserem Engagement im
Rahmen von Demokratie leben wir stärken
junge Menschen und wir stärken
Demokratie indem wir all jene
unterstützen die sich für unsere
Demokratie einsetzen 200 Millionen Euro
stellen wir insgesamt dafür zur
Verfügung noch einmal 16,5 Millionen
mehr als im vergangenen Jahr und diese
Bundesregierung wird noch in diesem Jahr
den ersten Aktionsplan gegen
queerfeindlichkeit beschließen
die bitter nötig das ist das zeigt der
mörderisch homophobe Hass dem malte C
zum Opfer fiel
ein 25-jähriger Transmann wurde
erschlagen als er beim csd-städtefest in
Münster eine lesbische Frau vor Attacken
schützen wollte
das geht uns alle an
lgbtiq Menschen brauchen unseren Schutz
und wir werden mit dem Nationalen
Aktionsplan den Rahmen dafür geben
werte Abgeordnete Werte zuschauende es
geht um die innere Stärke unserer
Gesellschaft und das Zusammenhalten
besonders in Krisenzeiten wie diesen ich
bin überzeugt sie die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sie sehen das sie wollen das sie
verstehen dass wir in Krisenzeiten
zusammenhalten müssen und dass wir diese
Krisen gemeinsam bewältigen können und
zwar solidarisch sie registrieren auch
auf der anderen Seite wie Rechte und wie
demokratiefeinde aus der Krise aber
Profit schlagen wollen und behaupten die
da oben in den Regierungen von Bund und
Ländern die machten was sie wollen und
nehmen den normalen Menschen was weg
meine Damen und Herren das wird nicht
wahrer nur weil es immer lauter gebrüllt
wird die Folgen von corona-krieg und
Klimakrise ja die strapazieren die
Nerven und sich strapazieren die
Geldbörsen aber wir können diese
Aufgaben lösen wenn wir es zusammentun
und deshalb bitte ich Sie bitte Abgrund
aus den demokratischen Fraktionen um
ihre Unterstützung herzlichen
Lisa Pause Ministerin für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend hat in ihrem
Beitrag einen Schwerpunkt auf
kindergesetz deren Förderung etwa
sprachlichem Bildung und auf finanzielle
Sicherheit und das ganze natürlich vor
dem Hintergrund der corona-pandemie und
den dadurch erlittenen Defiziten für die
Unionsfraktion Silvia breher
familienpolitische Sprecherin
Frau Ministerin Paulus es ist ihr erster
Haushalt für das bmffj was sie hier
vorlegen und ihr Haushalt wächst das ist
auch gut und richtig und wichtig so es
wächst aber vor allen Dingen auf durch
die gesetzlichen Leistungen gesetzlicher
Ansprüche die bestehen und sie selber
verweisen darauf aufs Kindergeld dass er
angehoben wird das Kindergeld ist bis
auf ganz wenige Ausnahme überhaupt nicht
in Ihrem Haushalt verankert aber wenn
sie schon darauf hinweisen dass sie 18
Euro für jedes Kind drauf geben wollen
dann würde ich sagen vielleicht sprechen
wir auch noch mal über das dritte Kind
über das vierte Kind und über das fünfte
Kind für die nämlich diese 18 Euro nicht
gibt sondern es gibt sie nur für die
ersten und zweiten mehrkind-familien in
diesem Land gehen hier leider leer aus
in ihrem Haushalt sollte allerdings
einfach noch viel mehr stecken denn es
ist das
Familienministerium und die
Herausforderungen sind riesig und sie
Frau Ministerin haben in ihrer ersten
Rede in der April gesagt wie wichtig
ihnen Chancengleichheit für Kinder ist
ein Zitat von ihnen aus der rede ich
finde mich nicht damit ab dass Menschen
mit ihrem Talenten und Fähigkeiten auf
der Strecke bleiben nur weil sie
benachteiligt sind ich finde es wirklich
schade dass genau hier sie die
Unterstützung ihrer Koalition scheinbar
nicht haben denn in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag hatten sie noch was
ganz anderes verabredet und genau daran
wollen wir sie messen ihr Haushalt
versagt gerade im Bereich frühkindlicher
Bildung gerade wenn es um
Chancengleichheit geht völlig sie haben
im Koalitionsvertrag versprochen ich
zitiere das Bundesprogramm sprachkita
wollen wir weiterentwickeln und
bestätigen
verstädigen Ausrufezeichen ihre Politik
sie streichen dieses Bundesprogramm
sprachkita dieses Programm gibt es jetzt
im zwölften Jahr es ist bundesweit
erfolgreich mit über 7.500 Fachkräften
die gerade die Benachteiligten die
schwächeren Kinder beim Spracherwerb
unterstützen es sind Stärke entstanden
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher werden
weitergebildet die Einrichtungen
weiterentwickelt Sprache ist die
Grundlage für alles Sprache ist die
Grundlage für Chancen von Kindern egal
ob sie benachteiligt sind oder nicht und
genau das beenden Sie Ihre
Staatssekretärin hat auf unsere Frage
gesagt wir übergeben die entstandenen
und erprobten Strukturen und Ansätze in
die
Verantwortung der Länder nein sie
zerstören diese Strukturen sie verweisen
auf das qualitätsgesetz was da kommen
mag aber wir haben schon jetzt ein gute
Kita gesetzt schon jetzt sind zwei
Milliarden pro Jahr sie erhöhen diese
Mittel gerade nicht für die sprachkita
gab es im vergangen in den vergangenen
Jahren in diesem Jahr 248 Millionen
diese Mittel stellen Sie den Ländern
nicht zusätzlich zur Verfügung und es
gibt keine Absprache mit den Ländern
keine Verabredungen wie das denn bitte
zum ersten ersten 23 sich umgesetzt
werden soll laut ihrem Haushalt gibt es
am 1.1 keine 7.500 Fachkräfte mehr der
Finanzminister sagt dazu es wird keine
Verschlechterung in den Einrichtungen
geben sagen sie das mal den Leitern der
Einrichtungen deren Mitarbeiter jetzt
schon gekündigt haben weil sie am 1.1
keinen Vertrag mehr haben sagen Sie das
den Leitern dieser Einrichtungen wo die
Fachkräfte nicht wissen was am 1.1
passiert die die Kinder jeden Tag in
ihrer Kita haben die Hilfe brauchen die
genau die Sprachförderung brauchen und
das können Sie mit den Mitarbeitenden
die sie jetzt haben einfach nicht
leisten der Kollege von Malotki sagt
dazu von der SPD der Finanzminister
täuscht Fachkräfte und Eltern das
Bundesland Mecklenburg-Vorpommern SPD
regiert kündigt eine
Bundesratsinitiative dazu auf dazu an
hören Sie endlich auf zu streiten halten
Sie sich einfach nur an ihre eigenen
Zusagen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag und
setzen Sie das Programm fort
sie streichen nämlich nicht nur dieses
Programm die fachkräfteoffensive
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher eingestellt
zugesagt im chorvertrag ein
Investitionsprogramm zum weiteren Ausbau
von Kitaplätzen gibt es in Ihrem
Haushalt nicht die frühen Hilfen wollten
sie laut Koalitionsvertrag dynamisieren
was auch immer das heißt das Programm
schrumpft zurück auf vor drei Jahren
zurück Volumen nur noch 51 Millionen
Euro kann ich mal mehr der
Inflationsausgleich nicht mal die die
Lohn Mehrkosten sind drin und im
Anschluss haben Sie davon gesprochen ich
unterbreche sie weil die Redezeit fast
zu Ende ist und frage sie ob sie
inzwischenfrage von Herrn Fricke
zulassen will gut
das sind alles nur versprechen aus ihrem
eigenen Koalitionsvertrag und diese
halten sie nicht an wir und nicht nur
wir sondern auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die Kinder und Familien in diesem
Land werden sie einfach nur an ihre
eigenen Zusagen an ihrer aus ihrer
sogenannten zukunftskoalition für die
Zukunft der schwächeren der Kinder in
diesem Land ist da leider nicht viel
drin und wir werden da erheblich
Nachbesserungen einfordern und freuen
uns auf die Beratungen vielen Dank
Silvia breher aus der Unionsfraktion und
die und das zeigt auch dieser Beitrag
hier gibt sich in der Opposition
deutlich freigiebiger was
Sozialleistungen angeht als das zur
Regierungszeiten der Fall war jetzt eine
Zwischenfrage von Otto Fricke aus der
FDP-Fraktion sie haben jetzt ganz viele
Vorschläge gemacht was man alles was
diese Koalition noch alles an Dingen
verlängern müsse die sie als CDU die sie
abgewählt worden sind aus der Regierung
machen würden anstatt anstatt an Stadt
anstatt der Koalition und der Ministerin
die Möglichkeit zu geben das was in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung steht so
umzusetzen wie diese Koalition ist für
euch hält aber dennoch frage ich sie
nach dem was die sind jetzt alle weg
nachdem Entschuldigung stimmt nicht bis
auf den landesgruppenvorsitzende der der
eins zwei stolzen CSU nachdem was ihre
Vorgänger in der Rede zum Finanz zur
finanz-haushaltspolitik gesagt haben
frage ich sie jetzt werden sie all das
was sie kritisiert haben wo das Geld
fehlt und wo sie der Meinung sind der
Bund müsste das wieder für die Länder
machen wird die cdu/csu diese Anträge im
Haushaltsverfahren Stellen mit welchem
Wert oder ist das hier nur heiße Luft
Frau Bria zur Antwort
vielen Dank Herr Kollege wenn Sie mir
zugehört haben dann haben sie sehr wohl
mitbekommen dass ich gesagt habe ich
messe sie an ihren eigenen versprechen
da ich habe sie zitiert aus ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag und ich habe die
Ministerin zitiert aus ihrer eigenen
Rede und zum Thema sprachkita ja wird es
von uns einen entsprechenden Antrag und
ein Finanzierungsvorschlag geben und so
habe ich mich bislang auch jedes Mal
eingelassen vielen Dank
der nächste Redner ist ein kleines
Zwischenspiel war das zwischen Silvia
und breja und Otto Fricke und auf dem
Weg zum Pool ist Sönke Rix SPD-Fraktion
dort stellvertretender Vorsitzender
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen mehr wir haben ja
zusammen
in den hallo
Silvia wir haben ja zusammen in den
vergangenen
vergangenen Jahren regiert und es war
auch nicht alles schlecht muss man auch
dazu sagen jetzt ist es vieles
allerdings jetzt ist vieles allerdings
besser und ich will
und ich will da ganz kurz noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass wir immer
gemeinsam der Auffassung waren da wo die
Länder originär die Zuständigkeit haben
unterstützen wir Sie gerne aber wir
wollen dass Sie Ihre originären
Zuständigkeiten auch wahrnehmen ihre
Aufgaben auch wahrnehmen und
ich weiß es ganz genau Nadine schön und
Markus Weinberg haben das immer wieder
betont das war übrigens auch der Grund
warum die Union gar nicht auf die Idee
gekommen wäre ein gute Kita-Gesetz auf
den Weg zu bringen das haben wir als
Sozialdemokraten damals in den
Koalitionsvertrag gebracht das war nicht
ihre Idee die Union war eigentlich
damals dagegen ein bundesweites
qualifizqualifikationsqualifizierungsgesetze
auf einmal entdecken Sie in der
Opposition auf einmal entdecken Sie in
der Position ihre Zuneigung zur Kita ist
ja schön ist ja gut ist ja wunderbar
entdecken Sie die bitte aber auch in den
Ländern in denen sie Verantwortung
tragen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Sprache Sprache ist Grund Sprache ist
ist die Sprache ist die Grundlage für
alles haben sie gerade eben gesagt und
wenn man den Koalitionsvertrag genau
liest denn steht da wir wollen das
Programm oder beziehungsweise wollen die
Qualität die sprachkitas die
Sprachförderung verstetigen was bedeutet
das für ein Gesetzgeber verstetigen ist
ein ein Gesetz überführen und kein
Programm und keine Projekte macht das
sind die Grundlagen so verstetigen wir
als Bundesgesetzgeber und wir überführen
es in ein Gesetz und zwar ins
qualitätsgesetz und das ist auch richtig
so aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir wissen schon es gibt jetzt hier
Strukturen vor Ort da müssen wir jetzt
bei den Haushaltsberatungen noch mal
darauf achten dass wir die auch nutzen
damit die erfolgreich ins
qualitätsgesetz überführt werden können
aber so ist es bei Haushalten da gucken
wir noch mal als Haushaltsgesetzgeber
drauf und versuchen diese Strukturen da
eine Übergangslösung zu finden wie als
Sozialdemokraten auf jeden Fall werden
dazu bereit
ich habe zwei Familien getroffen in den
letzten Wochen wir waren alle unterwegs
eine erzählte mir sie hatten einen
Baugrundstück bei mir in Eckernförde
sich gekauft und das mussten sie
zurückgeben weil die Preise so massiv
gestiegen sind eine andere Familie
erzählte mir sie wollen auf den
Nachmittagsbetreuung verzichten ihres
Kindes weil sie zu teuer ist weil sie
sich aufgrund der Preissteigerung lieber
erstmal die Lebensmittel und die
Haushalt und das Haus und so weiter
finanzieren müssen das sind dramatische
Situationen die angekommen sind bei
Familien bei denen wir eigentlich
gedacht haben sie sind auf dem er auf
der Ebene dass sie gar nicht viel
staatliche Unterstützung brauchen aber
sie brauchen gerade in der Zeit jetzt wo
die Energiepreise und allgemein die
Preissteigerung sehr stabil sind sie
brauchen diese Unterstützung und das ist
gut dass wir im letzten Maßnahmenpaket
und das ist das dritte Maßnahmenpaket
was jetzt die Koalition auf den Weg
gebracht hat gerade diese Familien auch
in den Blick nehmen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
nicht nur durch die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes auf 500 Euro die Ausweitung
des Wohngeldes die Einführung einer
strompreisbremse die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes und Erhöhung des
kinderzuschlages unterstützen wir nein
wir unterstützen natürlich auch weiter
denn wir haben einerseits die Aufgabe
ins System einzugreifen beispielsweise
über die strombremse aber andererseits
auch die Aufgabe dauerhaft für
Entlastung Unterstützung zu sorgen und
deshalb wird diese Koalition auf die
Kindergrundsicherung einführen nach den
Hilfspaketen kommt auch die dauerhafte
Lösung und das ist die Kinder
Grundsicherung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
denn im Gegensatz zu dem was im Moment
bei der Union vorgetragen wird sind wir
schon länger dafür auch Familien
dauerhaft zu entlasten und entdecken
nicht plötzlich erst die Zuneigung für
Kitas und Familien wenn Oppositionen
angekommen sind dafür arbeitet diese
Koalition herzlichen Dank
die Rednerinnen für die AFD ist Marianne
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der naive hat
geglaubt dass die FDP in der Ampel als
Korrektiv linker Politik wirken könnte
der Realist wusste dass es anders kommt
und der vorliegende haushaltsland gibt
dem Realisten recht linke und
pseudoliberale sind letztlich zwei
Seiten derselben Medaille und die vielen
FDP Wähler die das anders sahen kommen
sich jetzt betrogen vor Sanktionen gegen
Russland bald Sanktionen gegen China
eine
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte die
deutsche als Kartoffel beschimpft und
ein selbstbestimmungstes Gesetz mit dem
bereits Jugendliche im Jahrestakt ihr
Geschlecht wechseln können dieser
Wahnsinn ist auch made by FDP aber
Christian Lindner säuselt im
weltinterview die FDP verhindere einen
Linksruck Hofer braucht man die FDP
überhaupt noch im für gar nichts und die
politische Linke wiederum hat die
Menschen aufgegeben die früher in ihrem
Fokus standen Arbeiter sozialbedürftige
rentnerfamilien werden sie sich nun
vorrangig sexuellen ethnischen oder
sonstigen Minderheiten widmet ein Blick
in den vorliegenden
familienhaushaltsplan macht diese
falsche Prioritätensetzung besonders
deutlich die Mittel für die
Bundesstiftung Gleichstellung sollen um
zwei Drittel erhöht werden und auch
generell werden mehr Mittel für
Gleichstellungspolitik veranschlagt
lassen Sie doch einfach Frauen Frauen
und Männer Männer sein statt sich
ständig in ein gleichstellungskorsett zu
zwingen Schluss mit diesen politischen
Geschlechtsumwandlungen und besonders
dreist ist die Erhöhung der Mittel für
die Förderung per Maßnahmen zur Stärkung
von Demokratie und Vielfalt was blumig
klingt es nichts anders als Linke
kadersubventionierung und die ist auch
noch üppig bemessen hörst 184 Millionen
Euro sind für diesen Haus arztposten
vorgesehen das sind 33 Millionen Euro
mehr als im Vorjahr und fast doppelt so
viel wie 2020 das freut natürlich
Ex-Star sie Mitarbeiterin Khane die als
Chefin der Antonio Amadeus Stiftung mal
wieder zu den Begünstigten zählen wird
sie hat erklärt die größte Bankrott
Erklärung der deutschen Politik nach der
Wende sei es gewesen dass sie zugelassen
habe dass ein Drittel des Staatsgebiets
weiß blieb Deutschland im Jahr 2022 das
ist wenn ehemalige stasi-funktionäre uns
staatlich subventioniert in Fragen der
Demokratie und Vielfalt belehren wollen
und was die einen bekommen das wird den
anderen eben genommen die Mittel für die
Förderung des Ehrenamtes werden mal eben
um zwei Drittel gestrichen die Mittel zu
Unterstützung gewaltbetroffener Frauen
mit Kindern werden nicht erhöht das wäre
bitter nötig denn die Frauenhäuser
platzen dank ihrer Migrationspolitik aus
allen Nähten und die Zuschüsse für
Aufgaben der Politik für ältere Menschen
und dem demografischen Wandel werden um
etwa 3 Millionen Euro gekürzt dabei ist
die demografische Entwicklung unseres
Landes eine Katastrophe die Geburtenrate
liegt deutlich unterhalb des Bestands
erhaltenen Niveaus seit 50 Jahren
sterben mehr Menschen in Deutschland als
geboren werden ihre trinkste politische
Aufgabe wäre also diese demografische
Katastrophe abzuwenden zum Beispiel
indem man familiensteuerliche entlastet
oder das Familiensplitting einführt die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Artikel des
kinderbedarfs senkt eine Kultur des
Lebens fördert die Hilfen für Schwangere
und
kinderlose ausbaut etc das wäre mal
Politik für das eigene Volk aber was
machen sie gerade drei Prozent des
Gesamthaushaltes sind für den
Familienhaushalt eingeplant 600 Euro
weniger als zuvor und das würden sie
noch große Teile für linksideologisch
Projekt und natürlich für ihre eigene
Parteijugend vorgesehen mitten in einer
von ihrer Politik herbeigeführten
Energie und Wirtschaftskrise in der
Familien jeden Cent brauchen könnten
aber sie sie beschwören ein
abtreibungskult sie greifen die
traditionelle Familien und die
demografische Entwicklung dient Ihnen
als Vorwand für offene Grenzen und für
noch mehr Migration und nein da
dramatisiere ich nichts ein
Landtagsabgeordneter der Grünen immerhin
Regierungspartei fordert ja ganz offen
Zuwanderung bis zum Volkstod mit
Zuwanderung bis zum Volkstod kann man
vielleicht aus linker Sicht die
demografische Krise lösen aber man
schafft so tausend neue Probleme
fassen wir also zusammen
[Applaus]
wir sollen Flagge zeigen aber nicht die
schwarz-rot-goldene sondern am besten
die regenbogenfarbene wir sollen 67
Geschlechts akzeptieren aber unser
eigenes in Frage stellen wir sollen
alles Fremde lieben aber das eigene
nicht wir sollen frieren gegen Putin
kalt duschen fürs Klima den Gürtel enger
schnallen während der deutsche Staat
noch mehr Geld für linke
kadersubventionierung politische
Geschlechtsumwandlung und Zuwanderung
bis zum Volkstod ausgibt der Großteil
dieses Hauses trägt diesen Irrsinn mit
und nur eine Kraft wehrt sich dagegen
nämlich die Alternative für Deutschland
vielen Dank
Marianna Hader Kühnel aus der
afd-fraktion und auch sie sagt nicht
dass die Ursache der Energiekrise im
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine liegt
und die damit verbundenen liefer
Reduzierungen bzw sogar der Lieferstopp
von russischem Gas nach Deutschland
claudia raffelhöschen ist die nächste
Rednerin aus der FDP-Fraktion wir haben
jetzt wieder eine Runde mit rauseltern
die sich zum Haushalt des Einzelplans
der Familienministerin äußern nein ich
gehe da jetzt nicht drauf an nein schon
zum zweiten Mal in diesem Jahr beraten
wir ein Haushaltsentwurf für den
Einzelplan 17 und um die banalste wie
bitterste Wahrheit gleich am Anfang
auszusprechen die Rahmenbedingungen sind
im Vergleich zum Haushalt 22 nicht
besser geworden gerade deshalb bin ich
jedenfalls sehr froh dass wir am
ehrgeizigen Ziel unseres
Koalitionsvertrages festhalten und die
Schuldenbremse ab diesem Haushalt 23
wieder einhalten
denn wir ahnen einerseits alle dass die
weltpolitische Situation und sicherlich
noch auf Jahre hinaus massenhaft Gründe
geben würde viel staatliches Geld zu
verausgaben und vieles an
finanzpolitischer Vernunft über Bord zu
werfen
andererseits wird uns gerade brutal vor
Augen geführt was exzessives Schulden
machen und die geldflutungspolitik der
EZB bewirken galoppierende Inflation
lohnen preisspiralen und wie in den USA
oder Osteuropa zu besichtigen die
Anfänger einer Wirtschaftsrezession mit
allen unschönen Nebenwirkungen für
innere Sicherheit und politische
Stabilität
insofern also gut dass wir in
Deutschland eine Schuldenbremse haben
und sie nun auch wieder nutzen ich freue
mich sehr dass der Einzelplan 17 trotz
der widrigen Gesamtumstände im Vergleich
zum soll
2022 um
280,6 Millionen Euro steigt und nun bei
knapp 13 Milliarden Euro liegt die
größte Steigerung mit einem Plus von 550
Millionen gibt es beim Elterngeld das
ist ein gutes Signal und bestätigt
wieder dass das Elterngeld einer der am
meisten geschätzten Familienleistungen
Deutschland ist wir erreichen damit drei
Dinge gleichzeitig wer sichern die
wirtschaftliche Existenz der Familien
wer entlasten Eltern was oft vergessen
wird auch die Unternehmen bei der
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf und
wir ermöglichen Eltern und zwar bei
beiden Eltern sich Zeit für ihr Kind zu
nehmen
der Kinderzuschlag steigt um 101
Millionen und auch das ist eine
Familienleistung die im Leben der
betroffenen Kinder ein positiven
Unterschied macht
auch wenn wir uns alle einig sind dass
sie spätfolgende Pandemie gerade bei
Kindern und Jugendlichen nach längst
nicht überwunden sind kann die
Konsequenz dennoch nicht sein dass wir
uns im dritten Jahr der Pandemie immer
weiter in einem Ausnahmezustand
Einrichten der heute Gott sei Dank nicht
mehr so gegeben ist wie noch vor zwei
Jahren um diese Zeit dass wir ohne
Lockdown und Homeschooling auch kein
Programm
corona-auszeit für Familien mehr haben
ist kein trauriges Zeichen sondern ein
sehr gutes für mich als freie liberale
decken sich hier Finanz- und
gesellschaftspolitische Ziele ich
wünsche mir für unsere Kinder mehr
Normalität und weniger Sondermaßnahmen
an dieser Stelle ein ganz großes
Dankeschön an die Ministerin Pause und
stark Watzinger dafür dass sie sich so
klar gegen weitere Kita und
Schulschließung ausgesprochen haben die
Kosten
die Kosten die durch noch mehr
psychische Schäden bei Kindern
garantiert entstehen würden können wir
uns wirklich im Sinne des Wortes sparen
gerne investieren wir dagegen in eine
gute Kinderbetreuung und frühkindliche
Bildung vor allem Sprachkompetenz der
Bund hat seit 2008 satte 5,4 Milliarden
Euro in den Kita-Ausbau gesteckt und
seit 2019 noch mal 5,5 Milliarden in die
Umsetzung des Gute kita-gesetzes für die
Weiterentwicklung dieses Gesetzes sind
für 23 und 24 nochmal jeweils zwei
Milliarden Euro vorgesehen und das alles
obwohl
Kinderbetreuung grundsätzlich erst
einmal Ländersache ist und vor diesem
Hintergrund finde ich die künstliche
Empörung der letzten Woche über das
planmäßige Auslaufen des Bundesprogramms
sprachkitas nach sage und Schreiben elf
Jahren einigermaßen befremdlich
zumindest zeugt sie von einem seltsam
föderalismusverständnis der Bund zahlt
und die Länder bestimmen hier würde ich
mir neben den Grundsätzen der Haushalt
Klarheit und Haushalt Wahrheit
zusätzlich den Grundsatz der Haushalt
Fairness wünschen
in der Vergangenheit haben leider viele
Länder Bundesgelder genutzt um
Kita-Gebühren und zwar unabhängig vom
Einkommen der Eltern zu kürzen oder ganz
abzuschaffen wenig überraschend wenig
überraschend hat nun die Evaluation
ergeben dass eine stärkere Priorisierung
auf die Verbesserung der Qualität gelegt
werden sollte darunter die Verbesserung
des Betreuungsschlüssels qualifiziertes
Fachpersonal und für mich ganz zentral
die sprachliche Bildung ich bin daher
froh dass die Länder mit der
Weiterentwicklung des
kita-qualitätsgesetzes künftig
überwiegend also über 50 Prozent der
Gelder in die sieben vorrangigen
Handlungsfelder investieren sollen aus
meiner Sicht dürften es gerne 100% sein
die in die Qualität gesteckt werden
in diesem Sinne freue ich mich auf die
weiteren Beratungen und unseren
gemeinsamen Einsatz für die Kinder und
die Familie vielen Dank
Claudia rasselhöfen aus der FDP-Fraktion
wir sind immer noch im Einzelplan 17
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend und
dazu spricht jetzt Gesine Lötsch
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
und haushaltspolitische Sprecherin
Kinder sind in unserem Land ein großes
Armutsrisiko insbesondere für
Alleinerziehende das ist eine Schande
und das muss geändert werden meine Damen
und Herren und auch das
Kinderhilfswerk Unicef hat der
Bundesregierung ins Stammbuch
geschrieben die Bundesregierung tut zu
wenig um Kinder vor Armut und Gewalt zu
schützen die Politik müsste endlich
deren wohl in den mitpunkt Stellen die
Kollegin Raffelhüschen von der FDP hat
gerade noch einmal die unsinnige
Schuldenbremse verteidigt und sie hinter
die Überschrift
Generationengerechtigkeit gestellt die
Wahrheit ist genau andersrum die
Schuldenbremse ist eine zukunftsbremse
sie gefährdet die Zukunft unserer Kinder
und Enkelkinder sie verhindert dass den
Bau von Kitas Schulen und Infrastruktur
und das ist ungerecht die Schuldenbremse
gehört wirklich auf den Müllhaufen der
Geschichte
Frau Paus sie haben hier wieder über die
Einführung der Kindergrundsicherung
gesprochen ein wichtiges Projekt das
Ihnen sicher bestimmt persönlich am
Herzen liegt aber sie haben es in diesem
Haushalt nicht durchgesetzt und ich
finde es ist doch unerträglich dass es
der Ampel gelungen ist innerhalb von 100
Tagen 100 Milliarden Euro für die
Rüstung locker zu machen und vier Jahre
soll es dauern bis die
Kindergrundsicherung kommt wer soll so
eine Politik ernst nehmen das ist
garantiert keine Politik für Kinder und
Jugendliche das muss ich ändern meine
Damen und Herren
Kinder und Jugendliche sind immer die
ersten Opfer in der Krise in der
Pandemie wurden als erstes die
Spielplätze und dann die Schulen
geschlossen und in der aktuellen
Gaskrise war einer der ersten Vorschläge
von Bundesminister Harbeck doch die
öffentlichen Schwimmbäder nicht mehr zu
beheizen ich finde das ist ein fataler
Vorschlag denn kein Mitglied dieser
Regierung hat gefordert zum Beispiel
Übungsflüge der Luftwaffe zu reduzieren
umschreibstoff zu sparen nur eine Zahl
das Kampfflugzeug F35 verbraucht in der
Stunde
5.600 Liter Treibstoff das ist doch
nicht zu akzeptieren das könnten wir
einsetzen und für Kinder und Jugendliche
etwas sinnvolles zu machen meine Damen
und Herren
und es hat eine unheimliche Symbolkraft
wenn die Ampel jetzt das Programm für
sprachkita streicht mit diesem Programm
hat der Bund seit vielen Jahren das ist
ja erwähnt worden zusätzliches Personal
für die Sprachentwicklung im Kitas
finanziert in den vergangenen Jahren
haben viele Einrichtungen davon
profitiert und wenn jetzt dieses
beliebte Programm abgewickelt werden
soll angeblich weiterentwickelt aber das
steht ja nicht im Haushalt drin dann ist
das ein fatales Signal es kostet dem
Bund gerade einmal 200 Millionen Euro
ein Witz im Vergleich zu den 64,5
Milliarden Euro die die Bundeswehr
allein in diesem Jahr bekommt ich sag
ihnen mal ein Zahlenvergleich wenn Sie
nur ein U-Boot weniger bauen würden dann
hätten sie das Geld für diese
Sprachprogramm zusammen meine Damen und
Herren jedes fünfte Kind in Deutschland
gilt als armutsgefährdet das ist nicht
mehr sozial ungerecht sondern ist auch
schlecht für die Gesellschaft
kann sich dadurch schlechter entwickeln
vielen Dank
Gesine Lötzsch für die Linksfraktion in
der Debatte zum Einzelplan 17 bzw dessen
Etat und wir sehen und hören als
nächsten Bruno höhnel Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen des Familienministeriums
wächst an und das in einer schwierigen
Zeit im Vergleich zum 22er Haushalt
steigen die Ausgaben um 280 Millionen
insgesamt also rund 12,9 Milliarden für
Familien vom Kita bis ins Rentenalter
aber eben auch für unsere lebendige
Demokratie und den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt das ist zuallererst einmal
ein gutes Signal zur richtigen Zeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine ernsthafte Analyse des Einzelplans
muss im Kontext der fiskalpolitischen
Gesamtsituation erfolgen und damit eben
auch im Angesicht der Krisen den wir
gegenüberstehen und genau das führt uns
zu zwei Realitäten die ich kurz umreißen
möchte die Haushaltslage ist angespannt
das wissen sie alle wir haben durch den
Krieg in der Ukraine unsere humanitären
und
sicherheitspolitischen Verpflichtungen
aber eben auch durch die Teuerung und
die massiven Entlastung die wir
finanzieren massive Mehrausgaben nun
reduzieren wir aber trotz dieser
Mehrausgaben die Nettokreditaufnahme von
139 Milliarden auf 17 Milliarden um die
Schuldenbremse einhalten zu können dass
erfordert natürlich eine gewisse
Ausgaben Kritik und davon ist der
Einzelplan 17 eben auch nicht
ausgenommen die zweite Realität ist eine
enorme Diskrepanz der Haushaltssituation
von Bund und Ländern im Mai 22 hatte die
ländergesamtheit ein positives
Finanzierungssaldo von 11, drei
Milliarden die Tatsache ist die Länder
haben die finanzielle Ausstattung um
ihre landeseigenen Aufgaben auch zu
schultern und
vor diesem Hintergrund dieser beiden
Realitäten die ich beschrieben habe
verstehe ich auch die Angriffe der Union
hier nicht sie können nicht auf der
einen Seite in Sonntagsreden immer die
schwarze Null hochhalten aber auf der
anderen Seite im parlamentarischen
Haushaltsverfahren fordern jeden zweiten
Titel im Haushalt zu erhöhen das passt
nicht zusammen dafür muss man kein
Mathematiker sein um festzustellen dass
das nicht geht das ist unseriös
das ist eine unseriöse Haushaltspolitik
liebe Kolleginnen zu den sprachkitas hat
die Ministerin schon ausgeführt klar ist
dass wir über das kita-qualitätsgesetz
und den Schwerpunktbereich
Sprachförderung den Ländern die
Möglichkeit geben das Programm
weiterzuführen sie müssen diese
Möglichkeiten eben nutzen und genau
dafür hat die Ministerin hart verhandelt
damit wir unser Versprechen dass
kita-qualitätsgesetz auf den Weg zu
bringen einlösen können das ist gelungen
insgesamt vier Milliarden stellen wir
dafür in 2023 und 24 bereit das ist
nötig weil Kind Kitas eben nicht nur ein
Ort der Betreuung sind sondern vor allem
auch ein Ort frühkindlicher Bildung und
Sozialisation der Ort wo das Fundament
für Chancengerechtigkeit gelegt wird
unser Motto ist klar und einfach
Qualität ist Priorität und genau das
prägt dass Kita qualitätsgesetz
ein weiterer Erfolg ist das
zukunftspaket für Bewegung Kultur und
Gesundheit im Umfang von 50 Millionen
Euro die Ministerin sorgt dafür dass die
Erfolge der ausgelaufenen
corona-programme nicht einfach
versickern sichert eine
Anschlussfinanzierung und das
unterstützen wir natürlich weil es
geboten ist nach Jahren der Entbehrungen
aufgrund der corona-situation vor allem
für unsere Jüngsten liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen lassen Sie mich
abschließend sagen dass Ministerium hat
weniger Handlungsspielraum als in den
letzten Jahren obwohl an sich mehr Geld
zur Verfügung steht
2023 fließen 550 Millionen mehr in das
Elterngeld der wachsende Ansatz ist gut
im Sinne der Vereinbarkeit von Familie
und Beruf die wir ja gemeinsam auch
massiv fördern aber der Titel bindet
eben auch Haushaltsmittel die dann im
Programmbereich fehlen am Ende sind wir
also wieder bei der Realität vom Anfang
unter Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse sind
Abstriche an einigen Stellen
unumgänglich trotzdem finanzieren wir
das not einige gehen darüber hinaus mit
diesem Einzelplan mit dem
kita-qualitätsgesetz wir haben jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch
Handlungsspielräume wir sollten Sie
nutzen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
herzlichen Dank
der nächste Redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ist der Kollege Dr
Hermann-Josef tierbrocke
frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer auf den Rängen und an den
Empfangsgeräten wir als CDU CSU werden
nicht müde die Bedeutung den Wert der
Familie immer wieder herauszustellen und
uns auch in der Politik ganz konkret für
Familie einzusetzen insofern begrüßen
wir natürlich auch die Debatte zu dem
Einzelplan 17 wobei gerade schon
deutlich gemacht worden ist dass der
Einzelplan 17 und das was dort
abgebildet ist nicht alleine das
ausmacht was Familie betrifft meine
Damen und Herren was ist von Familien in
den in der zurückliegenden corona-krise
alles geleistet erlitten worden wo wären
wir als Staat eigentlich wenn wir die
Familien nicht hätten die so viel auch
für uns als Staat als Gesellschaft
geleistet haben und jetzt kommt die
ukraine-krise die Energiekrise die
Inflation ist kommen Zukunftsängste dazu
und wieder sind es Familien und gerade
mit Kindern zumal mit mehreren Kindern
sind Alleinerziehende Familien
Pflegenden Angehörigen die
überproportional betroffen sind zum
einen weil die Preissteigerung vor allem
Produkt- und Dienstleistungen betreffend
die vom familiennach gefragt werden und
zum anderen weil Familien im
Durchschnitt ein geringeres Einkommen
zur Verfügung haben und damit diese
Krise nicht so leicht wegstecken können
ich glaube darüber besteht weitestgehend
Einigkeit und es wird auch vieler Orten
immer wieder Anerkennung zum Ausdruck
gebracht wir sagen aber es braucht auch
konkrete Unterstützung zwar schneller
und mehr als das hier geplant ist vor
diesem Hintergrund liegt die Ampel liegt
die Regierung einen Haushaltsplanentwurf
2023 vor
der
als wie sagte der Staatssekretär donka
als gute Grundlage für die
parlamentarische Beratung die möge das
macht deutlich das auch hier die FDP der
Finanzminister davon ausgeht ausgehen
muss dass noch intensiv nachgebessert
werden muss und wenn und das möchte ich
an dieser Stelle sofort auch klarstellen
in Richtung von Herrn Dr Fricke auch von
Frau ravelichen sagen wenn da für die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse votiert
wird dann geschieht das auch in uns mit
unserer Unterstützung weil wir glauben
gerade auf sich der Familien gehört zu
einer nachhaltigen Politik eben auch die
Berücksichtigung der nachfolgenden
Generation dienen das abzutragen hat was
wir hier möglicherweise leichtfertig
verausgaben
aber meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
ist dieses wuchtige Paket mehr als
wuchtig ist es eigentlich auch klug und
vor allem ist es familienfreundlich und
das ist eine Frage die ich insbesondere
an sie Frau Familienministerin richten
möchte und dabei meine ich nicht nur die
Analyse und Bewertung des Einzelplans 17
ich glaube Familie und Politik geht weit
über das hinaus und ihre Verantwortung
reicht weit über das hinaus was im
Einzelplan sitzenden abgebildet wird
Familien brauchen Infrastruktur brauchen
Zeit aber sie brauchen auch konkret Geld
und ich möchte an dieser Stelle
insbesondere auf die steuerpolitischen
Beiträge eingehen die ja dazu auch
angelegt sein können Familie zumal in
dieser Situation zu unterstützen und es
macht mich zuversichtlich voraus als
ehemaliges Mitglied des
Finanzausschusses und insbesondere auch
mit steuerpolitischen Fragen dass sie
sehr
konstruktiv mit dem Vorschlägen umgehen
die wir als Union unterbreiten möchten
konkret auf steuerpolitische Fragen bei
der Gestaltung des Steuersystems das was
in Zukunft auch hier zu beraten ist
warum gelingt es nicht mehr und
konsequenter auch die Liste der
mit ermäßigem Steuersätzen belegten
Umsätze zu diskutieren zu untersuchen
geradeaus sich der Familien was ist mit
den Lebensmitteln immer noch mit 19
Prozent besteuert werden was ist mit
Hygieneartikeln zu Versorgung von
Kindern was mit der Kinderkleidung und
Kinder schon die wir mit sieben Prozent
besteuern können statt mit 19 Prozent
ein schneller Beitrag zu Hilfe Familie
ich komme zum zweiten Punkt was ist mit
ersparnishilfen für Familien für junge
Familien könnten wir neben Unterstützung
etwa im Bereich der
Arbeitnehmersparzulage der
wohnungsbauspräge bausprämie nicht auch
mehr machen im Bereich der
Grunderwerbsteuer Freibeträge um
Vermögen zu bilden was ist mit der
Erhöhung des sparer-pauschbetrags für
kleine Sparer für Familien die Vermögen
bilden wollen und sich damit schützen
wollen vor Inflationsrisiken
oder das dritte das machen wir sehr gern
Herr Dr Fricke wir helfen Ihnen dabei
wenn das so noch nicht von ihnen
vorbereitet wir haben auch einige
Vorschläge zur Einkommensteuer wir haben
einen wir könnten uns einen
energiekostenfreibetrag vorstellen
darüber gibt es ein Vorschlag als
Alternative zu dem 300 Euro für alle
Paket wir stellen uns eine Anpassung der
Kinderfreibeträge vor auch eine
Anpassung der des Kindergeldes und die
Kolleginnen wer hatte bereits darauf
hingewiesen dass wir nicht
nachvollziehen können wie da
argumentiert wird wir haben
Unterstützungsmöglichkeiten im Bereich
der haushaltsnahen Dienstleistungen
völlig chaotisch organisiert lassen Sie
uns das aktualisieren lassen Sie uns das
Straffen ich glaube wir tun viel für die
Familie und nicht zuletzt die
Alleinerziehenden zu entlasten hatten
wir wieder auf hohl vorgeschlagen ich
verstehe eigentlich auch die Fraktion
der Linken nicht die ja hier Frau lütsch
betont wie sehr die Alleinerziehenden
ihr am Herzen liegen aber die
Unterstützung für unsere Anträge
schuldig bleiben meine Damen und Herren
Familien verdienen Anerkennung und sie
brauchen mehr Unterstützung Frau
Präsident Frau Ministerin wir erwarten
von Ihnen dass Sie über die Ansätze im
Einzelplan 17 hinaus mehr für Familien
erkennbar tun zum Beispiel im Bereich
der Steuerpolitik die wir versichern
Ihnen Ihre Unterstützung wir sind eine
konstruktive
Opposition er ist insbesondere an den
familiengelegen ist herzlichen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit
Josef tebrookhaus der Unionsfraktion und
ihm wird jetzt folgen Elisabeth Kaiser
aus der SPD-Fraktion sie ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend aber auch Sprecherin für
Strategien gegen Rechtsextremismus
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr geehrte
Bürgerinnen und Bürger liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen mit Blick auf den Herbst
und Winter ist für uns in der SPD klar
wir tun alles dafür den
Herausforderungen infolge des russischen
angriffskriegs insbesondere den enormen
Energiepreisen wirksam zu begegnen denn
nur so sichern wir den Zusammenhalt in
unserer Gesellschaft mit den Beschlüssen
vom Wochenende hat die Koalition einmal
mehr bewiesen dass sie in Zeiten großer
Krisen handlungsfähig ist und dass ich
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
auf uns verlassen können die Ausweitung
des wohngeldanspruchs eine
strompreisbremse Steigerung beim
Kinderzuschlag und Kindergeld endlich
300 Euro Direktzahlungen für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner 200 Euro für
Studierende und fachschüler:innen all
das und mehr sind Maßnahmen die vor
allem Familien beziehen von kleinen und
mittleren Einkommen aber auch Menschen
im Alter zielgenau entlasten
als ostthüringerin sind mir das
besonders wichtige Anliegen weiß ich
doch um die großteils immer noch
geringeren Löhne geringeren Renten und
kaum vorhandenen Vermögen die man
bräuchte um die preissteigerinnen in
Folge von Inflation und die hohen
Energiekosten abfedern zu können wir
müssen aber damit rechnen dass die
aktuelle Lage länger andauert als wir
alle hoffen die nun bevorstehende
Beratungen zum Bundeshaushalt 2023
stehen deshalb auch weiterhin im Zeichen
dieser enormen Herausforderung ein klar
ist dabei auch dass Bund und Länder
gemeinsam in der Verantwortung stehen
die Folgen der Krise zu bewältigen
das trifft auch das trifft auch auf
viele Bereiche des Bundes
Familienministeriums zu mit Blick auf
den Haushalt 2023 für das
Bundesministerium für Familie Frauen
Senioren und Jugend verlässt sich
zunächst feststellen dass die Mittel um
280 Millionen Euro steigen und das
obwohl die Gelder aus dem
corona-aufholprogramm Auslaufen Gründe
dafür sind das mehr Menschen gesetzliche
Leistungen die Elterngeld Anspruch in
Anspruch nehmen und aber auch vom
verbesserten Unterhaltsvorschuss und
Kinderzuschlag profitieren und das ist
gut so denn mit den gesetzlichen
Familienleistungen erreichen wir eine
bessere Vereinbarkeit von Familie und
Beruf wir unterstützen Alleinerziehende
und wir helfen Familien mit geringen
Einkommen und zugleich ist unsauber als
SPD wichtig dass mehr getan werden muss
um Kinder davor zu schützen in Armut
aufzuwachsen die Kindergrundsicherung
das ist seine Leistung die wir bündeln
wollen unbürokratisch zusammenführen
wollen für Kinder das ist das größte
Projekt auch mit unserer Koalition mit
der wir Kinderarmut Objektiv bekämpfen
wollen
Armut von Kindern das ist aber nicht nur
der Mangel an monetären Ressourcen
sondern oft verbunden mit Bildungsarmut
entwicklungsdefiziten sowie psychischen
und sozialen Störungen Studien belegen
Kinder aus armen Familien bleiben häufig
ihr ganzes Leben langarm und das darf
nicht sein an Kindern und Jugendlichen
dürfen wir nicht sparen
die vier Milliarden Euro die seitens des
Bundes für die Weiterentwicklung des
gute kita-gesetzes bzw für das Kita
qualitätsgesetz in den kommenden zwei
Jahren zur Verfügung stehen sind deshalb
ein wichtiger und wichtiger Posten für
die Kinder in unserem Land
positiv positiv möchte ich auch die 50
Millionen Euro für das neue
zukunftspaket Bewegungskultur und
Gesundheit erwähnen denn das ist gut
angelegtes Geld um Einsamkeit
Bewegungsmangel von Kindern und
Jugendlichen zu begegnen und in der
frühen Lebensphase nachhaltig zu
unterstützen frau Kaiser möchten Sie
eine Zwischenfrage von Frau Bär zulassen
löschen
Zusammenhalt Gemeinschaft und Teilhabe
so wichtig das für Kinder und
Jugendliche ist wenn Sie sich zum
Beispiel im Sportverein engagieren so
wichtig ist das auch für unsere
Demokratie erst das vielfältige
zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement macht
Demokratie lebendig und wehrhaft gerade
mit Blick auf die erstarkenden
Demokratie feindlichen Kräfte gilt es
dieses Engagement zu unterstützen in
diesem Zusammenhang freue ich mich
persönlich sehr dass der Titel für
Demokratie Förderung und
extremismusprävention 2023 um weitere
16,5 Millionen Euro aufgestockt wird
damit
stehen in diesem Land insgesamt 200
Millionen Euro bereit ein Rekordwert und
ein tolles Signal für die vielen
Menschen in unserem Land die sich
tagtäglich für Demokratie engagieren und
wo Licht ist da ist manchmal auch
Schatten und der Entwurf enthält noch
einige Punkte mit denen ich noch nicht
ganz zufrieden bin und so werden zum
Beispiel die Mittel für die an Schulen
so wichtige Arbeit der Respekt Coaches
sowie die Kommunikationsdienste die wir
zusätzlich in 22 mit rein verhandelt
haben jetzt nicht mehr fortgeschrieben
insgesamt sinken die Ausgaben für die
Kinder und für den Kinder und jugendplan
dem wichtigsten Förderinstrument auf
Bundesebene im Bereich der Kinder und
Jugendhilfe und das liegt vor allen
Dingen Auslaufen der corona-hilfen wir
sollten aber immer auch die Folgen im
Blick behalten die solche Kürzungen nach
sich ziehen und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass wir in der ein oder anderen Stelle
da noch nachbessern können und freue
mich auf die Beratungen und die gute
Zusammenarbeit vielen Dank
der Kollegin Bär gebe ich das Wort für
eine Kurzintervention ja liebe Frau
Kollegin Kaiser schade dass ihr meine
kurzen knappen nachfragen die ihnen auch
noch mal die Möglichkeit gegeben hätten
vielleicht zu sagen was sie vorrangig
zugelassen haben deswegen an dieser
Stelle zum einen würde uns sehr
interessieren wenn das Thema
Kindergrundsicherung immer so ein ganz
großes Thema ist wie sie es finden dass
noch nicht mal alle Arbeitsgruppen
getagt haben in der Regierung schon ein
bisschen Zeit ins Land gegangen Punkt
zwei wir bewerten Sie das um den Umgang
mit dem dritten und vierten und fünften
Kind was meine Kollegin Bär ja auch
schon aufgeworfen hat also zählen nur
erste und zweite Kinder also ich
besonders persönlich ganz schade finde
für alle die wirklich kinderreiche
Familien sind und das dritte ist wer hat
Recht in ihrer Fraktion Frau Kollegin
Kaiser sie oder Herr von Malotki wenn
wirklich das Thema sprachkitas kein
Problem ist warum gibt es dann eine
Petition ihres Kollegen der direkt neben
Ihnen sitzt also vielleicht können Sie
das mal auflösen innerhalb ihrer
Fraktion da werden wir sehr daran
interessiert
[Applaus]
zur Antwort frau Kaiser
Frau Kollegin ich glaube wir sind uns
einig dass uns Familien und Kinder in
diesem Land sehr wichtig sind ich denke
Sie sollten die gesetzgebende Verfahren
jetzt abwarten zur Kindergrundsicherung
da sind wir auf einen guten Weg und zu
der anderen Frage natürlich alle Kinder
in diesem Land wichtig und auch gerade
auch die sprachkitas das habe ich auch
meiner letzten Haushaltsrede sehr
deutlich gemacht und ich habe auch
erwähnt dass ein Bund und Länder
gemeinsam in der Pflicht wir setzen das
fort indem wir eben auch die zwei
Milliarden für 20 23 und 24 einstellen
in den Bundeshaushalt und denken dass
wir dann guten Weg finden dass da keine
Erzieherin kein Erzieher keine Pädagogin
keine Pädagogen Angst haben muss dass es
nicht weitergeht
für die AFD ist die nächste Rednerin
Ulrike schicke Ziesing
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin meine Damen und
Herren das zweite Mal in diesem Jahr
debattieren wir den Haushalt des
Familienministeriums das zweite Mal in
einem Jahr in dem viele Familien mit
Sorge in die Zukunft schauen und
natürlich erwarten die Familien von
ihnen Frau Ministerin dass es in dieser
Krise Entlastungen gibt das ist Hilfen
gibt für die Familien und für die Kinder
um die Krise für Sie abzufedern aber
leider ist der Haushalt in dieser
Hinsicht eine große Enttäuschung ja der
Etat für Familien ist um fast 250
Millionen Euro gewachsen damit rühmt
sich die ganze Koalition gewachsen ist
aber ihr Teil lediglich wegen der
gesetzlichen Leistung sie wissen ganz
genau dass diese automatisch steigen das
ist nicht ihre Politik das sind per
Gesetz errechnete Leistungen
alle in der Unterhaltsvorschuss und das
Elterngeld steigen um circa 600
Millionen Euro man muss kein Mathegenie
sein um festzustellen dass die 600
Millionen nicht gleich sind mit den 250
Millionen mehr bei den allgemeinen
Ausgaben andersrum ihr Ministerium hat
ordentlich gespart aber wo genau zum
Beispiel in der Kinder- und
Jugendpolitik ganze 470 Millionen -
findet man da das sind die Bereiche der
freien Jugendhilfe die
Qualifizierungsoffensive oder
Einsparungen bei den Stiftungen früher
Hilfen allein bei den sogenannten
sprachkitas und dem Kita
einstiegsprogramm wurde ordentlich
gekürzt mehr als 260 Millionen ja die
Programme laufen aus haben wir hier
schon gehört aber das muss kein
Automatismus sein hier wäre eine
politische Entscheidung fällig hier
könnten sie zeigen dass ihnen die
Kita-Kinder nicht egal sind es ist eine
politische Entscheidung gewesen diese
Programme auslaufen zu lassen und es den
einzelnen Ländern zu übertragen ob sie
es gerne machen würden oder nicht und es
ist eine falsche politische Entscheidung
das einzige plus das man übrigens in
diesem Kapitel findet ist der
Neugeschäft eine Titel für ein
zukunftspaket für Bewegung Kultur und
Gesundheit während wir als afd-fraktion
diesen Titel zumindest im Ansatz
unterstützenswert finden ist das Volumen
doch ein schlechter Scherz ausgerechnet
der Titel der die vergeigte
corona-politik der vorranggänger
Regierung und mit Herrn Lauterbach auch
dieser Regierung ausgleichen soll soll
mit nur 50 Millionen Euro die immensen
Schäden die bei den Kindern entstanden
sind ausgleichen das ist nichts ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein immerhin
ein Funken Reue wird darin ersichtlich
die Rechnung aber dürfen mal wieder die
familiengrößtenteils alleine tragen
ähnlich ist es auch mit ihrem großen
Wurf Kinderzuschlag 21 Euro mehr im
Monat 21 Euro die der Großteil Familie
der Familien nicht bekommt da die
Voraussetzungen so eng geschnitten sind
21 Euro die bei einer realen Inflation
ein Witz sind diese 21 Euro sind in
diesen Tagen einen hohen für viele
Familien lieber Ampel
auch die Not versprochenen 18 Euro mehr
Kindergeld können die folgende Inflation
für die Familien nicht mal ansatzweise
lindern wie diese Erhöhung finanziert
wird wie insgesamt die vielen
Versprechen der Ampel für das nächste
Entlastungspaket finanziert werden
sollen steht in den Sternen wir werden
sehen ob der Finanzminister bis zu
Verabschiedung des Haushalts einen Weg
zu Finanzierung gefunden hat Frau
Ministerin ich kann mich noch sehr gut
daran erinnern wie wir im Dezember
letzten Jahres an dieser Stelle über
unsere Vorschläge zu Bekämpfung der sich
bereits damals anbahnenden Inflationen
diskutiert haben damals waren sie zwar
noch nicht Ministerin aber immerhin die
finanzpolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion und was haben sie uns damals
erzählt dass die Inflation Zitat
erstaunlich wenig beträgt mehr noch
gemeinsam mit ihrer koalitionskollegin
Frau kizitäte von der SPD haben sie doch
allen Ernstes vor der Deflation gewarnt
und allgemein die Entwicklung schön
geredet ich glaube mittlerweile muss es
auch in den allerletzten Reihen ihrer
Koalition angekommen sein handyverteil
falsch ihrer Einschätzung und
finanzexpertise war und wie sehr sie die
Gefahren der Inflation unterschätzt
haben übrigens all dies war weit vor dem
Überfall auf die Ukraine mir scheint als
ob die ukraine-krise mittlerweile zu
einem idealen Sündenbock für alles was
seit längerem schon schief läuft
geworden ist das soll von den
eigentlichen Problemen ablenken nämlich
dass es ihre Regierungspolitik ist und
war die uns in diese Lage gebracht hat
und sie haben anscheinend auch nicht
viel daraus gelernt anders kann ich mir
die weiteren falschen Entscheidungen wie
etwa die gasumlage oder die inzwischen
völlig verfehlte Sanktionspolitik nicht
erklären diese bewusste Entscheidung
oder das völlige leugnen von Problemen
bringen inzwischen unzählige Familien an
den Rand der Verzweiflung das ist bitter
und das muss auch gesagt werden
meine Damen und Herren es wird viel zu
besprechen sein in den
Haushaltsberatungen ich kann für mich
und meine Fraktion ankündigen dass wir
eine Reihe an Anträgen Stellen werden wo
wir mehr Ausgaben sehen wollen etwa bei
den Entlastungen der Familien auf der
anderen Seite gibt es viele Positionen
in denen wir kürzen werden etwa da wo
Geld sinnlos verfeuert wird Frau
Ministerin lieber ampelregierung wir
leben in turbulenten Zeiten es ist
allerhöchste Zeit dass sie die
Scheuklappen ihrer Ideologie ablegen und
entsprechend ihrem Amtszeit Handeln
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Jensen hat jetzt das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion und güdingensen ist
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zu der
vorvorrednerin der AFD hätte ich am
liebsten gesagt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Fraktion regieren wir doch
einfach so dass die AFD damit ein
riesiges Problem hätte und ich glaube
dann sind wir auf einem guten Weg
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wenn wir als Kinder und
jugendpolikspolitiker hier über den
Haushalt sprechen dann haben wir hier
immer ein ganz grundlegenden
konfliktpräsent den vielleicht der ein
oder andere auch erst wieder bemerkt hat
seitdem die FDP in dieser
Bundesregierung vertreten ist und zwar
unsere Schuldenlast ist eine Hypothek
für kommende Generationen wir haben die
Verantwortung unseren Kindern
Staatsfinanzen zu hinterlassen und sie
nicht noch mit weiteren Ballast zu
belasten in die Herausforderungen für
die nächsten Generationen die werden
nicht geringer werden gut an dieser
Stelle dass wir einen Finanzminister
haben der auf das Geld achtet und auch
eine Bundesregierung die genau diesem
Kurs des Finanzministers folgt und den
Mitglied und dann ist da die andere
Seite und zwar die Seite die wir glaube
ich hier auch alle unterschreiben
könnten nämlich dass jeder Euro in die
Zukunft von Kindern und Jugendlichen
eine Investition in die Zukunft ist eine
Investition auch in eine gerechtere
Gesellschaft denn gute Startbedingungen
machen Kinder stark und sie stellen vor
allem die Weichen für ein Leben voller
Chancen und deshalb sind die Mittel im
Etat gegenüber dem bisherigen Finanzplan
gestiegen und zwar obwohl Mittel aus dem
Corona aufholprogramm obwohl aus dem
ergänzungshaushalt Mittel Auslaufen ich
glaube das ist eine wunderbare Nachricht
zusätzlich investieren wir aber nicht
nur aus dem Etat für das BMFSFJ in gute
Startchancen für die Kinder sondern eben
auch aus dem Finanzministerium und da
kommen für das kita-qualitätsgesetz das
hier schon entsprechend mehrfach
Erwähnung fand 4 Milliarden Euro in den
nächsten zwei Jahren also eine
maßgebliche Unterstützung für beste
Kitas und zwar überall in Deutschland
das hat die Ministerin gesagt als Freie
Demokraten haben wir schon lange
gefordert dass die Bundesmittel in
Teilhabe in Qualität in der
Kita-Betreuung investiert werden anstatt
in pauschale Gebührenfreiheit und diese
Beitragsfreiheit die wird ja gerne in
Wahlkämpfen genutzt aber ich glaube wir
sind uns hier in der Koalition einig
dass vor allen Dingen dieses überwiegend
und meine Kollegin claudia
raffel-hüchner hat es angesprochen dass
mehr als 50% Qualität gehen ein
unglaublich wichtiges Zeichen ist und
das Schreiben wir jetzt in das Gesetz in
das qualitätsgesetz und sorgen dafür
dass tatsächlich auch in Deutschland
Standards gesetzt werden wir
unterstützen dabei nämlich genau dort
das Kinder in die Kita gehen können
unabhängig vom Wohnort unabhängig vom
Einkommen ihrer Eltern und zwar in eine
Kita die personell gut ausgestattet ist
auf individuelle Bedürfnisse der Kinder
eingeht und flexible Betreuungszeiten
bietet und im übrigen das wird manchmal
in solchen Debatten vergessen in solchen
Einrichtungen arbeitet es sich ja auch
viel lieber also auch die Erzieherinnen
und erzieherpädagoginnen und Pädagogen
die haben Lust in solchen Einrichtungen
ihren Beitrag zu leisten weil diese
Möglichkeiten und die Rahmenbedingungen
gegeben sind und die viel angesprochenen
sprachkitas ja wir ermöglichen den
Ländern dass sie diese Bundesmittel zum
Beispiel in der Sprachförderung nutzen
und hören Sie auf von der Union ja hier
so zu tun als würden sprach Kitas
abgeschafft werden übrigens gerade
deswegen wenn wir hier sitzen und dann
mit darüber streiten in diesem Haushalt
dass es wichtig ist draußen zu erklären
was hier eigentlich passiert und ich
erlebe momentan eher eine Angst in den
Verbänden bei Erzieherinnen und
Erziehern die sagen uns wird gesagt
unser Job ist weg sorgen sie helfen Sie
uns doch dabei dafür zu sorgen nein
helfen Sie uns dabei dass die Mittel mit
den Ländern sie sind doch in den Ländern
präsent Daniel Günther
Schleswig-Holstein beispielsweise rufen
Sie ihn an sorgen Sie dafür dass sie
gemeinsam dass sie gemeinsam die Mitte
die ja im Verhältnis sogar aufwachsen
können weil mehr in Qualität investiert
werden kann genau für Sprachförderung
eingesetzt wird hören Sie auf uns in der
Koalition die wir hier gemeinsam
miteinander ringen um die beste
Förderung für Kinder obwohl wir
grundgesetzlich nicht mehr zuständig
wären dafür zu sorgen dass Qualität in
den Kitas genau und was passiert wenn
eine Projekt was passiert wenn ein
erfolgreiches Projekt in die
Verstetigung geht wir haben das hier
schon gehört
das bedeutet dass wir an die Länder die
Verantwortung übergeben mit Mitteln des
Bundes weiterhin in Sprachförderung zu
investieren und das ich finde das
wirklich traurig dass sie hier in der
Debatte nicht eindeutiger dazu Stellung
nehmen wir freuen uns sehr auf die
konstruktiven hautaushaltsberatungen
aber wenn hier Menschen zuhören und
nicht Teil des Ausschuss der
Ausschussarbeit sind finde ich kann man
hier auch mal erklären was es am Ende
bedeutet in einer Zeit wo die
Haushaltslage extrem angespannt ist
dennoch jeden jedes Jahr zwei Milliarden
Euro für die nächsten zwei Jahre zur
Verfügung zu haben und festgesetzt zu
haben dass wir mehr in Qualität in
Sprachförderung investieren können ein
letzter Punkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir müssen dafür sorgen und ich
bin da der der Ministerin auch der
Bundesbildungsministerin sehr dankbar
dass wir dafür sorgen konnten in den
verhandlungserfolgen jetzt was das
Entlastungspaket anbelangt das vor allen
Dingen auch der Kinderzuschlag anwächst
das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema es wird
hier viel von Kindergeld Erhöhung
gesprochen aber vor allen Dingen der
kinderzus ist so zielgerichtet als
Instrument und unterstützt Familien die
zum Beispiel sich eher über die sich
eher darüber Gedanken machen müssen ich
komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin das
nächste Essen auf den Tisch zu bringen
oder eine Winterjacke zu kaufen und wir
freuen uns auf die Beratung die
konstruktiv sein mögen und ich hoffe
sehr dass wir es schaffen draußen
rückzumelden was wir hier wirklich tun
im Sinne von Familien und auch im Sinne
der sprachkitas
cute Jensen von der FDP-Fraktion
verweist nochmal das hier ist natürlich
ein arbeitsparlament und deswegen wird
ja viel Arbeit auch da gemacht wo wir
sie nicht unbedingt übertragen in den
Ausschüssen gürkei Akbulut spricht jetzt
für die Linksfraktion sie Sprecherin für
Familie
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen während viele Familien Kinder
und Jugendliche noch mit den Folgen der
corona-krise kämpfen kürzt die
Bundesregierung 40 Prozent der Ausgaben
für Kinder und Jugendpolitik die rasant
steigende Inflation treibt vor allem
geringverdienende Familien im Namen in
die Armut der sofortzuschlag von 20 Euro
pro Kind wird von der Inflation
regelrecht aufgefressen im Moment wir
hatten bereits bei der Einführung
kritisiert dass 20 Euro viel zu gering
sind auch die angekündigte Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes um 18 Euro für das erste
und zweite Kind ist einfach lächerlich
das reicht ja nicht mal für eine maxive
windelpackung und ab dem dritten und
vierten Kind soll das ganze auch
überhaupt nicht mehr erhöht werden und
wer Hartz IV bezieht Frau Paus hat von
der Kindergeld Erhöhung ohnehin nichts
es ist einfach untragbar dass das
Kindergeld mit dem hartz-iv-
während für die Bundeswehr wieder
gigantische Summen in diesem Haushalt
zur Verfügung gestellt werden wird im
Bildungs- und Familienbereich weiterhin
gekürzt der Kita-Bereich ist mit 20
Milliarden seit Jahren chronisch
unterfinanziert wir fordern daher ein
echtes Kita qualitätsgesetz was seinen
Namen auch gerecht wird und vom Bund
dauerhaft mitfinanziert wird es kann
nicht sein dass die seit Jahren
steigenden Kosten am Ende der Geschichte
wieder auf die Kommunen und Länder
abgewälzt werden außerdem ist es fatal
dass das
Bundesprogramm sprachkitas nicht
weitergeführt wird betroffen von den
Kürzungen sind über
525.000 Kinder und rund
6.800 Einrichtungen sprach Kitas sind
vor allem dort zu finden wo Familien mit
besonderen Problemen lagen oder
Migrationsgeschichte leben die Grünen
und die SPD verschärfen hier die
bildungsungleichheit und brechen ihren
eigenen Koalitionsvertrag
das Bundesprogramm sollte mit jährlich
260 Millionen Frau Pauls wieder
fortgesetzt werden sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren das groß angekündigte und
gefeierte dritte Entlastungspaket der
ampelparteien ist bei genauen Hinsehen
völlig unzureichend und wird immer mehr
Menschen in existenziell die Nöte
drängen in den nächsten Monaten deswegen
gehen wir als LINKE auf die Straße mit
vielen Bündnispartnern und fordern
lautstark den Gaspreis der Kinder und
die Einführung der übergewinnsteuer
Kollegen
[Musik]
zum Schluss gekommen sein wir haben
weder die Straßen überlassen und von
Links führen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Dennis Lob hat das Wort für Bündnis 90
die Grünen
Denise Lob ist ob Frau in
Familienausschuss für ihre Partei
Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen es sind schwierige Zeiten um
über ein Haushalt zu beraten der Krieg
in der Ukraine die Energiekrise und die
immer noch anhaltenden Auswirkungen der
corona-pandemie und gerade in dieser
Zeit mit diesen Herausforderungen halte
ich ein Einheiten der Schuldenbremse für
höchst fragwürdig und kontraproduktiv
denn wir müssen doch bewährte Projekte
erhalten und fortführen damit wichtige
Strukturen nicht wegbrechen mehr denn je
brauchen Familien Kinder und Jugendliche
jetzt verlässliche Unterstützung und
Angebote
wie in ihrer Rede schon erwähnt ist das
Bundesfamilienministerin dieser Paus
gelungen viele dieser guten Projekte und
Angebote im Regierungsentwurf
abzusichern und das zeigt auch in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten bleiben wir als
Ampelkoalition handlungsfähig
[Applaus]
doch der massive Spardruck ist auch in
unserem Einzelplan zu spüren für uns
parlamentarier:innen heißt es daher nun
dass wir die Belange der Menschen nicht
vergessen dürfen die in haushalterischen
Debatten oft nicht im Vordergrund stehen
wir müssen uns daher für notwendige
Vorhaben stark machen deren Finanzierung
bisher noch nicht gesichert ist ein
Beispiel für ein solches Vorhaben ist
die Kampagne der Unabhängigen
Beauftragten zu Fragen des sexuellen
Kindesmissbrauch
diese Sensibilisierungskampagne ist
bereits fertig geplant und trotzdem sind
bisher keine Mittel für die Umsetzung
und Weiterentwicklung im Haushalt
vorgesehen deshalb möchte ich als
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Familie
Seniorinnen Frauen und Jugend an dieser
Stelle noch einmal die Bedeutung und die
Notwendigkeit dieser Kampagne
hervorheben
dennoch immer werden jährlich tausende
Fälle sexualisierter Gewalt an Kindern
zur Anzeige gebracht aber ein weitaus
größer Anteil bleibt im Dunkelfeld es
ist davon auszugehen dass in jeder
Schulklasse ein bis zwei Kinder von
sexualisierter Gewalt in ganz
unterschiedlichen Kontexten betroffen
sind ob in der Schule selbst in der
Freizeit oder in der Familie laut einer
Phase Umfrage aus dem letzten Herbst
halten es 90 Prozent der Befragten für
wahrscheinlich dass sexualisierte Gewalt
an Kindern vor allem in Familien oder im
sozialen Nahraum stattfindet und
gleichzeitig halten es 85% für
unwahrscheinlich oder sogar
ausgeschlossen dass es in der eigenen
Familie bzw im engen Umfeld passiert
oder passieren kann und diese Diskrepanz
in der Wahrnehmung bei Erwachsenen muss
verändert werden und ich spreche
und ich spreche ganz bewusst von
Erwachsenen denn sie sind ist die Kinder
vor sexualisierter Gewalt schützen
müssen sie müssen für die Anzeichen
sensibilisiert werden und vor allem das
Handlungswissen haben dass Sie dagegen
tun können
sexualisierte Gewalt an Kindern kann nur
verhindert werden wenn wir alle diesen
Gedanken zulassen dass es sehr wohl auch
die eigenen Kinder oder Kinder die man
kennt treffen kann und genau da setzt
diese Kampagne der Unabhängigen
Beauftragten an
neben der Sensibilisierung und
Aufklärung ist auch die Förderung von
Dialog und Austausch Teil der Kampagne
außerdem ist geplant dass lokale
Netzwerke gegen sexualisierte Gewalt
aufgebaut und dafür multiplikator:innen
ausgebildet werden das Ziel ist es
Menschen zu befähigen gegen
sexualisierte Gewalt aktiv zu werden
liebe Kolleginnen die Regierung hat
einen Entwurf für den Haushalt vorgelegt
aber letztendlich entscheidet das
Parlament das ist unser Hoheitsrecht da
können wir als Parlamentarierin auch
Akzente setzen die viel bewirken ich
freue mich wenn wir diesen Kampf gegen
den sexualisierte Gewalt an Kinder
setzen und fünf Millionen in die
Sensibilisierungskampagne investieren
das würde auch die wichtige Arbeit der
Unabhängigen Beauftragten stärken und
wertschätzen ich freue mich auf gute
Beratung vielen Dank
Anne Janssen hat jetzt das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und Anne Janßen sitzt
im Ausschuss für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
dürfen in diesem Jahr bereits zum
zweiten Mal über einen Entwurf des
Bundeshaushalts und damit auch den
Einzelplan 17 debattieren und
selbstverständlich freue ich mich an
halbes Jahr nach dem Haushalt 22 über
den gestiegenen gestiegenen Etat für das
nächste Jahr auch wenn dieser Anstieg
verhältnismäßig klein ist so sind knapp
300 Millionen Euro viel Geld wenn sie
sinnvoll und nachhaltig eingesetzt
werden und genau hier bedauere ich die
Einschränkungen im Bereich der überhaupt
für Programme und Förderungen zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel denn unsere
Seniorinnen und Senioren profitieren an
als einzige Zielgruppe des Ministeriums
nicht von den festgesetzten gesetzlichen
Leistungen und bilden auch sonst keinen
Schwerpunkt in diesem Entwurf immerhin
haben sie das Thema Einsamkeit zu einem
wichtigen Vorhaben erklärt und das ist
eine richtige und notwendige
Schwerpunktsetzung mir sind in diesem
Zusammenhang auch ihre neuen Maßnahmen
bzw eine konkrete Maßnahme nämlich die
Gründung des Kompetenznetzwerks
Einsamkeit nicht entgangen warum sie
aber im gleichen Zuge die Zuschüsse und
Leistungen für Zwecke an Träger und für
Aufgaben der Politik für ältere und
einsame Menschen und knapp zwei
Millionen Euro eingekürzen erschließt
sich mir vor diesem Hintergrund nicht
ich würde sogar sagen dass ich hier ein
deutlicher Widerspruch zwischen Worten
und Zahlen ergibt im Juni 22 startete
intern endlich die Arbeit an der auch
von uns geplanten Strategie gegen
Einsamkeit das Strategiepapier benötigt
nun aber doch noch ein weiteres Jahr und
soll erst Mitte mehr in Mitte 23
vorliegen sollten Sie noch Anregungen
oder Ideen benötigen verweise ich gerne
auf unser bereits vor anderthalb Jahren
geschlossenes Positionspapier mit
konkreten Impulsen dass sie die
Strategie gemäß ihrem vorhab sogar noch
bis zum Ende der 20 Legislaturperiode
umsetzen wollen ist hoffentlich weder
ein Hinweis auf fehlende Quantität noch
Qualität sie nehmen sich viel Zeit zur
Planung Zeit die am Ende für die
Umsetzung fehlt und Zeit die die
Betroffenen nicht haben denn unsere
Mitmenschen sind bereut bereits heute
einsam und genau zu sein jetzt in diesem
Moment mehrere Millionen Betroffene sind
unfreiwillig Teil sozialer Isolation und
neben unseren Seniorinnen und Senioren
sind es auf junge alleinstehende und
Menschen mit Behinderung die aus
verschiedensten Gründen auf soziale
Teilhabe verzichten müssen und nach
einer mehrjährigen Pandemie sind es nun
die steigenden Preise die massive Folgen
haben werden denn zukünftig entscheiden
sich mit Blick auf die explodierenden
Gas- und Strompreise noch mehr Menschen
gegen kaffeebesuche mit Freunden gegen
Ausflüge mit der Familie gegen das
Eintrittsgeld fürs Kino gegen den
kostenpflich die Vereinssport oder gegen
andere gesellschaftliche Veranstaltungen
sie werden sich für eine warme Wohnung
und für heißes Wasser entscheiden müssen
und da helfen einmalig 300 Euro auch
nicht wirklich weiter
Armut stellt nach wie vor ein
bedeutendes Risiko für Einsamkeit da und
ein bekanntes und von uns auch gern
gefördertes Erfolgsmodell gegen
Einsamkeit in jeder Altersstruktur sind
die Mehrgenerationenhäuser denen sie
aber nach dem Ende des
corona-aufel-paketes auch die Mittel
kürzen ich bitte Sie also sehr sehr
geehrte
bundesseniorenministerin setzen Sie
keine falschen Signale und nehmen Sie
diese Hinweise in den anstehenden
Beratungen mit auf vielen Dank
Anne Janßen hat hier noch einmal auf die
Situation der Rentnerin und Rentner
verwiesen auch das war ja in den
Diskussionen zum Entlastungspaket Thema
in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ich möchte mit
etwas grundsätzlichem beginnen Frau
Ministerin Pauls sind Ende April in das
Amt gekommen und mehr oder weniger
direkt in die haushaltsverhandlung
gestartet Verhandlungen von die wir uns
alle gewünscht hätten dass die unter
anderem Bedingungen stattfinden mit
Blick auf die ausverhandelten zwei
Milliarden Euro jährlich für das
kita-qualitätsgesetz möchte ich Ihnen
meinen Respekt aussprechen
mit Blick auf die Gesamtsituation war
das alles andere als einfach es sehr
wichtig dass wir für diesen Nachfolger
das Gute kita-gesetzes im Haushalt die
finanzielle Förderung konstant halten
werden und dass wir es geschafft haben
einen besseren Ausgleich zwischen
erzielt der Teilhabe vieler Eltern und
der Qualitätsentwicklung zu erreichen
ich möchte kurz sagen was das für die
Kinder in meinem Bundesland bedeutet wir
können ein gesetzlich
mindestpersonalschlüssel endlich
einführen und wir können die
Verbesserung der Fachkräftesituation
durch eine Verbesserung der
dualorientierten Ausbildung auf den Weg
bringen das ist gut
aber jetzt jetzt sind wir als Parlament
gefragt wir alle kennen das
Bundesprogramm sprach Kitas so heute
schon oft Thema wir alle kennen den
Leitspruch des Programms weil Sprache
der Schlüssel zur Welt ist
wir alle wissen wie wichtig die
arbeitende sprachkitas ist sie sind
gelebte Praxis für mehr
Bildungsgerechtigkeit und genau deswegen
bescheinigen uns die Fachkräfte und die
Wissenschaft dass unser
sprachkita-programm das erfolgreichste
Programm des Bundes ist
in den vergangenen Jahren sind durch die
sprachkitas bundesweitsstrukturen
entstanden die sprachliche Bildung
fördern und damit gerade den Menschen
helfen die es nicht so einfach haben
über 500.000 Kinder und deren Familien
profitieren direkt von den sprachkitas
jede achte Kitas eine sprachkita jede
achte Kita
wir wollen die Erfahrung aus den
sprachkitas für alle anderen Kitas
nutzen um in allen Einrichtungen als
Bund die so entscheidende Sprachbildung
der Kinder zu unterstützen es deswegen
eine richtige Entscheidung die
sprachliche Bildung im neuen
kita-qualitätsgesetz zu stärken
aber wenn wir mehr Sprachbildung wollen
dann brauchen wir natürlich auch mehr
finanzielle Unterstützung des Bundes für
uns als SPD ist schon lange klar dass
der Bund mehr Verantwortung in der
frühkindlichen Bildung übernehmen muss
denn nur der Bund kann helfen
Bildungsgerechtigkeit im ganzen Land zu
gewährleisten es darf uns nicht egal
sein ob die Qualität der frühkindlichen
Bildung eines Kindes davon abhängt ob es
in Stuttgart Pirmasens Hagen oder in
Neubrandenburg wohnt
sprach geht das sind durch die
Bundesförderung auch deshalb die gelebte
Praxis des Versprechens nach
gleichwertigen Lebensverhältnissen
deshalb haben wir eine Verantwortung für
die Strukturen der sprachkitas und
dieser Verantwortung müssen wir gerecht
werden und Klarheit schaffen Frau Jensen
darauf hingewiesen wir müssen jetzt als
Bund und Länder
gemeinsam die Beschäftigten und Eltern
in den sprachkitas ein schnelles Signal
geben das ohne Unterbrechung in 2023
weitergeht ich bin deshalb stolz dass
sich die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion in
anstrengenden Haushaltsverhandlungen
dafür einsetzen wird dass die
sprachkitas eine Zukunft im Rahmen des
kita-qualitätsgesetz haben und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir in den nächsten
Wochen auch in der Koalition zu einem
guten Ergebnis im Sinne im Sinne unser
Kinder und ihrer sprachlichen Bildung
kommen werden
ich möchte mich zum Schluss meine Rede
bei den vielen Erzieherinnen Eltern und
Großeltern bedanken die sich für einen
Erhalt der sprachkitas einsetzen sie
sammeln Unterschriften gehen auf uns
Abgeordnete zu machen sich laut und